Õpetaja: Lähemale.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: okei, ee. Võibolla alustuseks räägiks hästi natukene nendest kastidest.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, et üks kohta nad pannud.
Õpetaja: Jah, siis peaks.
Õpetaja: See meil on nagu kõik.
Õpetaja: Noh, tõesti see teine, eks? See eelkõige see paber ongi välja kingitud Selle teise slaidi pärast Ütleme see, esimene
Õpetaja: Nii ma küsin, et, ee, mis on kontroller klassi Üks ja ainus ee eesmärk, Mis roll tal on,
Õpetaja: Mis te oskaksite mulle öelda,
Õpetaja: Täiesti Kogu pull. Jah, et ee põhimõtteliselt. See on siis selline klass,
Õpetaja: kuhu me saame defineerida veebiteenuseid, mida
Õpetaja: meie programmiliselt kuskilt ise ei käivita. Pole ühtegi koodirida.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus me käivitaksime mingisugust ee meetodit, et kui
Õpetaja: igal pool mujal. Kui nüüd edasi vaadata, on meie enda programmeeritud niiöelda näpujäljed Igal pool, nagu et me. Sõna otseses mõttes ütleme, et käivite see meetod ja käivite too meetod ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: siis ee, kontroller klassi Mõte on, seal, et seal siis on selline meetod, mida meie käivitada ei saa,
Õpetaja: aga saab käivitada keegi teine, kes see keegi teine on, Kes saab käivitada
Õpetaja: sõnad?
Õpetaja: No jah, sellet.
Õpetaja: Jaa, et me võime mõelda. Kutsume meie siis seda dispetšeriks niimoodi hellitavalt ja lühidalt,
Õpetaja: et Dispetšer on Siis see, et kui tuleb kõne sisse, siis ta tema tundub Okei, noh,
Õpetaja: nüüd ee. Seal. Kontrolleriklassis on mõned kohustuslikud niiöelda koodiread, millest ma Võibolla siin räägin,
Õpetaja: mis peab seal kindlalt olema, et üldse nagu dispetšer teaks, et ta peab vaatama sinna faili sisse.
Õpetaja: Noh, joonisel on ka tegelikult kõik info olemas.
Õpetaja: Fokusseerida sellele
Õpetaja: ja see adresse. Controller on Ee Springi veebi Ee Library klass ja See Annutatsioon annab siis seal klassi peal sellele klassile erilised võimed
Õpetaja: ja oskused ja meetodid. Ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas ta meile lihtsalt on, Siis nagu tähtis teada ongi, see, et ega enne dispetšer ei tea üldse sinna koodifaili sisse vaadata, et hakata otsima seal mingisuguseid
Õpetaja: kaardistusi ja Mingisuguseid meetodeid, Mida ta siis peaks käivitama
Õpetaja: ei pea. Kui paneme Atras Controller klassi peale, ära, siis ta nagu on sellest.
Õpetaja: No kui me kirjutame mingisuguse meetodi, ma ütlesin, et Spetser selle käibe tõmbab, Siis kuidas tema teab?
Õpetaja: Ee, mille abil Tema teab, et, ee, et ta peab mingisuguse meetodi just käivitama mingi konkreetse Sõnumi puhul,
Õpetaja: millest ma siin võibolla räägin.
Õpetaja: Mis on jälle nagu mingisugune ee. Eriline asi, mis? Nagu teeb kogu selle asja võimalikuks, et ta Dispetšer teab, et tema mingi hetk peab sõnum sisse. Ja ma. Siis kavatseb käivitada mingisuguse meetodi Meil,
Õpetaja: millest ma siin võibolla räägin, koodirea mõttest Ühele pildil on tegelikult olemas.
Õpetaja: Ei, see vist on juba päris action, Aga ma räägin seda Vaata, kuidas dispetšer selle teab, et ee, konkreetses Mingisugused kontroller klassis on
Õpetaja: mingis konkreetses Ee, kontrollerklassis. On Mingisugune meetod, mida tema peab siis mingi konkreetse sõnumi peale käivitama? Kuidas ta teab,
Õpetaja: et märk.
Õpetaja: Ja meil on seal niuksed, mapingud, Maping the League.
Õpetaja: Kui rääkida sellest Ee, Noh, sellise annutatsiooniga saame kaardistada, mida me seal sees kaardistame, Et mis on see Sisu? Mille järgi siis on? Nagu. Mis on siis siduv? Niiöelda info, mille abil
Õpetaja: ee siis, ee, me seome niiöelda neid ja tuleb Jah, kett sõnum. Aga mis seal mängib siis neid rolli?
Õpetaja: Kõrvad kinni ja see aadress kogu see rest. Ee, nii öelda Arhitektuuril. Ee põhinev. Niiöelda
Õpetaja: Ee, infosüsteem. Siis, ee mängib seal kahe osapoolega,
Õpetaja: et see meetod ütleb, et mida teha.
Õpetaja: Mis tegevus, on, Anna andmeid, Lisaandmeid, uuendandmeid, Kustuta andmeid,
Õpetaja: aga siis see Url defineerib ära põhimõtteliselt subjekti ressursi, et millest käib? Et
Õpetaja: et siis Ongi Ee need kaks poolt Defineerivad puhtalt ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle, et mida siis niiöelda peab käivitama,
Õpetaja: kui rääkida sellest, et, ee, kui dispetšer on see, sõber, kes nagu käivitab Seal kontroller klassis oleva meetodi. Siis
Õpetaja: nii ilusti on ära tehtud, et siis tuleb. Sõnum.
Õpetaja: Kuulub kellelegi. Teab, et see kuulub Atm Location Controller Ile. Noh, siin selle näiduse puhul teab, et kui tuleb sõnum siis kuskil seal klassis, on meetod Find Atm Locations, mille peale on pandud
Õpetaja: Nüüd, ee, kui kontrollerklassi ülesanne on ainult mingisuguse
Õpetaja: ee võimu tegevuse käivitamine sisse tuleva sõnumi peale,
Õpetaja: kus ma tegelikult päriselt hakkame seda asja niiöelda programmiliselt ära programmeerima, et, noh, kõik sammud, mis on vaja teha,
Õpetaja: et see tegevus niiöelda siis otsast lõpuni ära teha.
Õpetaja: Mis klassist ma nüüd Räägin Service klassist.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, siis kui me räägime Service klassist.
Õpetaja: Tema Jah, nagu pildil on ka nagu Niukene väike kelnerpoiss, kes muidugi siin Jookseb edasi tagasi ja toimetab. Ja, ee, delegeerib siin veel asjadele omakorda edasi. Seal tast vajab.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Aa, kui Meie, oleme meie kood, on kirjutatud Ee
Õpetaja: Controller klassis. Ja meie eesmärk on käivitada Ee, mingisugune niiöelda tegevus. Delegeerida edasi tegevus, Ehk siis neil peab olema ka selles service klassis. Ee, mingisugune meetod. Ahah, võibolla rääkides siin Service klassi, meetodist ja kontroller klassi meetodist,
Õpetaja: mis võiks olla siin ee mingisugune asi, mis ka jooniselt silma. Paistab,
Õpetaja: et, ee. Midagi, mida võiks. Nagu teada, et just nagu meetodite onju nimeosas,
Õpetaja: Kui vaadata neid nelja kaste, vaatate neid ee iga kasti sees olevat mingisuguse meetodi nime.
Õpetaja: Mis, ee, mis võiks märgata, et ee,
Õpetaja: mis mis on erilist kontroller ja sellist asja nii öelda Koos vaadates, mis neil on meetodi nimedega
Õpetaja: või siis omaval.
Õpetaja: No see peegeldab. See on okei, aga ma tegelikult otsin just siin, et kui vaadata nelja kasti ja meetodeid nende sees. Ja siis, nagu võrrelda neid kuidagi omavahel ja siis fokusseerida just selle kontroller kassile Sellistele asjale, siis Me võiksime meetodi nime puhul midagi märgata.
Õpetaja: Sama nimi, sama nimi. Lihtsalt me defineerime tegevuse kontroller klassi ja selle meetodi saab käivitada dispetšer neile
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd meie ise. Programmiliselt hakkame ka siin ju käivitama. Igasuguseid tegevused Me Deleteerime kogu selle tegevuse service klassi. Me peame sinna tegema mingisuguse meetodi, Mis siis hakkab seda ee probleemi niiöelda nagu lahendama. Ja nüüd siin võiks siis seda nagu kohe aru saada, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, need meetodi Nimed Selles mõttes. Ee, võiksid olla samasugused. Nad ei pea olema. Tehniliselt ei pea
Õpetaja: aga lihtsalt oleks veits kummaline, Vaata, kui ee, mingisugune tegevus, sest tegevus nii nagu Jaanus ütleb. See peegeldab tegelikult äriloogiliselt seda tegevust,
Õpetaja: aga see ei ole nii tehniline. Vaata, See on nagu, et Ei, mida mis? Tegevus hakkab meil siin serveris pihta, et kui kontroller klassis, mõtleme nagu välja mingi nime, mis peegeldab seda tegevust,
Õpetaja: siis see Realiseerimine tegelikult. Või see päris niiöelda? Ee, action Niiöelda äriloogika. Niiöelda Ee programmeerimine toimus seal Service klassis ja siin on samamoodi. Vaja siis mingid meetodid, mida käivitame
Õpetaja: ja lihtsalt äriloogiliselt. Seal ongi Business Logic. Vaata, et seal see sama äri loogiline nimi peabki lihtsalt edasi kanduma. Vaata, see Oleks nagu väga veider, kui esimene meetod oleks.
Õpetaja: Ja järgmine meetod näiteks ütleme. Ütleme, et ma ei tea. Update Locations või delete või või Ütle, Üld ütleb midagi muud, et Find Cities.
Õpetaja: Noh, Mis asja? Vaata, et ei saa olla ju. Vaata, et me käivitame põhimõtteliselt tegevuse,
Õpetaja: siis Miks peaks kutsuma meetod Find at Service klassis meetodid välja. Find cities. Näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ei, see tegevus jätkub lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult me ei saa seda tegevust sinna kontrollerklassi kirjutada. Me ei saa lihtsalt, sest et. Ee, muidu lihtsalt. Ee. See asi seal paisub. Ja see lihtsalt ongi. Ee, meil on siin eri nagu erinevad huvid erinevatel pooltel. Me soovime asju eraldada Me ei soovi, et kõik oleks ühes koodifailis
Õpetaja: ja siis sellepärast see tegevus Niimoodi suunataksegi järgmisesse niiöelda koodi faili kus siis hakkab nagu pikem action pihta,
Õpetaja: et kui mõnus on niimoodi, et kui mina, nagu puutun kokku mingisuguse
Õpetaja: ee. Veebiteenusega. Ja tegelikult läbi nende kontrolli. Nende uurijad ja asjade. Ma saaksin kohe leida üle projekti ülesse, nagu et see teenus algab Siit programmeerimise mets. Vaata
Õpetaja: mingi teenus, mis on süsteemis olemas. Tal on oma stardi pauk
Õpetaja: ja stardipaugud. On kõik seal. Kenasti Kontroller klassides on Täiesti eraldi kataloogides, näiteks. Noh, seda arhitektuuriliselt olla ka erinev, Aga idee järgi ma oskan kuskilt üles leida, nagu selle koha, mis mind huvitab,
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd see päris nii öelda. Äriloogika, kus tuleb päris palju Action eit.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis. See on kuskil mujal.
Õpetaja: Noh, sellepärast meil ongi tehtud niimoodi. Ja kui vaadata tõesti, et. Noh Näiteks, ee. Kui me vaatame seda Ee Service klassi, näiteks kui tema nool pikalt läheb sinna Location Repositori juurde. Seal on mingi Find Locations. Buy siin näitas.
Õpetaja: Noh, ei ole ju Siin on juba nagu mingi konkreetne ala alamtegevus, onju, et Seal seal, Ee, selles hoidlas on ee, selline meetod, mis kirjeldab, mida tema nii öelda nagu teeb, põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: okei, noh, ee, kui
Õpetaja: nüüd rääkida sellest, et, ee, et kuidas. Kui. Kui kõik need neli tükki on neli kasti, on tegelikult siis erinevad failid.
Õpetaja: Ja iga selle faili sees on Siis nimeline meetod. Mida ee, tahame siis välja kutsuda? Siis on küsimus, et ee. Kuidas kuidas saab seda teha,
Õpetaja: kuna kõik meetodid on Ee objekti, meetodid, Instantsi, meetodid. Ee, siis tähendab seda, et neid meetodeid on võimalik ainult käivitada. Niiöelda programmiliselt niiöelda läbi objektide
Õpetaja: nüüd objekte objektide poole. Saame pöörduda ainult ühel viisil, kuidas saame pöörduda objektide poole läbi minna
Õpetaja: sildi abil. Aga räägime nüüd nagu vanad programmeerijad Muuta jah,
Õpetaja: et Objekti muutuja kaudu, et meil. Aga noh, me võime ikka endiselt öelda. See siinkohalt, see kõnetad. Teid, on ju
Õpetaja: Ja mina ei saa rääkida Jarostlofiga. Kui ma ei tea tema nime, Vaata, et sa arvad. Näiteks onju
Õpetaja: küsimus, onju? Siis oleks väga keeruline. Vaata, kui klassiruum on õpilasi täis. Ma tahan Just peaks. Ee, oletame seda ka, et me oleme kõik pimedad.
Õpetaja: Pigedate klass.
Õpetaja: Võibolla saaks hakata keegi, et. No viipa näpuga Vaata küll, onju, et ee suhelda, Siis mul on vaja lihtsalt kuidagi tema poolt pöörduda. Ainukene moodus. Kuidas Efeki pool see pöörde on siin
Õpetaja: Nüüd, miks on see tähtis? Ongi see, et kui me vaatame seda Ee joonist ka siis me näeme, et seal Atm Location Controller is on niimoodi hästi lühendatud vormis üleval. Minu pilt on vist natuke teine, kui teil on ju?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas teil on seal teistmoodi Või ei ole, see on sama. Vaata, Okei,
Õpetaja: Jah, see kui seal on ka mingit väikest vahetust, see kuidagi on muutunud, et, ee, mis meil on siis vaja on. Ee. Esiteks, ee. Meil on siin pikes.
Õpetaja: Me näemegi, et seal kasti üleval on sildikene Atm Location Service, Kenasti Niimoodi lillakat värvi ka nii nagu ta meil sees on.
Õpetaja: Ja et see tähendab seda, et
Õpetaja: et me nii nagu me tegime, tegelikult frontend Is ka kui meil oli näiteks Navigation Service eraldi koodifail oli. Vaata, kus sees oli ära programmeeritud see asi, et kui sa tahad navigeerida Error Page Ile siis. Meil oli seal mingi
Õpetaja: ee. Punkt oli, et Mine näiteks error ruudil, et Neil oli mingid nimelised koodilõigud. Me soovisime neid käivitada.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt seal selles. Ee, niiöelda Java strip ist. Me saime viidata failile Niiöelda on ju? Aga meil oli ikkagi mingisugune nagu nimi Punkt Meetod on ju? Siin on sama mõte. Vaata, et meil on olemas objekt.
Õpetaja: Ee, korra räägime sellest. Miks Ad Service on vajalik. No Tal on palju põhjuseid, Mida ta seal, Miks, miks, ta on vajalik? Aga see asi, mida teie teate, miks peab olema sellel Service klassil Peal Ad service. Mis juhtub siis kui panna, Ad Service sinna peale?
Õpetaja: Miks ta on vajalik? Miks, miks ei või puudu olla?
Õpetaja: See on Vajalik Tõmbas mingi tere kohta.
Õpetaja: Seda lähed Ee, vales suunas Praegult
Õpetaja: Ma isegi vaatasime seda ka. Seda isegi visuaalset oli võimalik Ee demonstreerida. Visualiseerida?
Õpetaja: Mis juhtmed ütlevad?
Õpetaja: Kohvi juba. Oot, nüüd oleme lähemal.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis see tähendab seda vaata, et, ee. Kui meie paneme sinna, seal, on muid Aspekte ka, on ju Aga üks aspekt. Ja peamine aspekt, mis meid huvitab, on see
Õpetaja: et Spring ise teeb ee, kuskil Ee Springbuat ise oma karukohus Runtimel teeb Ee niukse koodirea nagu New Location Service.
Õpetaja: Ta teeb objekti
Õpetaja: sellest klassis ja ta paneb selle enda niuksesse mõnusasse konteinerisse, et kas temal on ligipääs Springida endale?
Õpetaja: Sprinconteiner on selle asja nimi
Õpetaja: Ehk kõik need ee annutatsioonid, mis on depositoril, ei pea olema kui Nad on printsiibis. Näete, meil on kõigil need annutatsioonid peal. Need annutatsioonid teevad erilisi asju. Nad lisavad
Õpetaja: ee nendele klassidele neid võimeid ja oskusi, Mis nendel klassidel endal on? Best Controller on klass. At Service on tegelikult klass. At Mapper on klass, on aga, noh, miks on kuidagi rääkida niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et põhimõtteliselt. Ee. Need need viited seal peal just annavad täpselt need võimed, mis nendele asjadele on mõeldud.
Õpetaja: Põhiline asi on See Niukene annutatsioon on olemas ka nagu komponent ringi omal. Põhimõtteliselt See on selle nende kõikide taustal on ka kuskil olemas
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt annate Springile märku, et ole hea Tee minust üks objekt. Hoia mind kuskil konteineris ja nüüd mina nagu vastavalt selle klassi tüübile. Tegelikult olen siis ee Kättesaadav üle koodifaasi. Nagu põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Ee, lihtsalt Need on ee erivormid siin. Vaata, nende kõigi taga Tegelikult on kaine component, mis tähendab seda,
Õpetaja: et Sellest asjast peab tekkima nii öelda objekt. No sellest, kui tehniliselt minna.
Õpetaja: Ei, lihtsalt ongi vaja teada seda. Vähe sellest, et ee, spetsialist arvab, et ta, teab, et tema peab siia sisse vaatama ja toimetama siin, ja vaatama neid kaardistusi, siis on vaja käivitada on samamoodi, Ee, üks nendest benefitidest. Noh, teate küll,
Õpetaja: on meie parim trend. Üks nendest benefitidest Ee ongi, see, et ee, tehakse sellest Atm Location Controllerist tehakse objekt
Õpetaja: Ee. Sellel Atm Location Servicel on Ad Service peal. Üks nendest benefitidest on see, et kuskil ka karukohus põhimõtteliselt jooksutamise. Hetkel Spring teeb New Location Service.
Õpetaja: Jah, näppäriga. Samamoodi võib ka teine. Niiöelda umbes nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd viimane asi on siis see, et okei, et ee, meil kõikidest nendest Ee, püsitegelastest tehakse objektid. Ee, pildiseeriatest mäletad olid? Olid kollased mälutulbad
Õpetaja: ja olid valged. Mälutulbad on ju? Ja kes need kollased on? Need, kes On kogu aeg olemas. Alates sellest hetkest server käib. See kollane ongi.
Õpetaja: Mis? Te vaatasite need õppematerjalid ära, mis? Panin ka tüsti.
Õpetaja: Noh, mõned Vaatasid Saite midagi aru ka? Noh, katkis neid samu teemasid, mis me eile arutasime, onju? Et Noh, miks see kõik on vajalik, onju
Õpetaja: nii Okei, nüüd Järgmine asi, mis seal joonisel vajab. Nagu tähelepanu on sulgudes D ja I Mis see D ja I on?
Õpetaja: Ee, see on Siis Ee, sõltuvuste kontroll. Ee, see on siis. Noh, teisipidi võib ka öelda, et. Ee, ma süstin sõltuvusi. See on siis selline, asi, et Ku, Kuidas on siis? Nagu see asi ära lahendatud, et kuidas nagu Spring põhimõtteliselt siis teab,
Õpetaja: et, ee, sinul on mingisugune muutuja ja kuidas Ta teab. Ja kuidas ta ka tehniliselt siis tegelikult saab.
Õpetaja: Ee, niiöelda ee, lisada ise. Niiöelda kui ta teeb nendest klassidest objekte
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, Ee, ta saab nende niiöelda sildikeste taha Connect Ida ära. Sest need objektid, mis tal seal springkonteineris on.
Õpetaja: See on see, et kuidas tema Manageerib meie ees seda, et me ei pea ridagi koodi nagu kuskil kirjutama, et ütlema nagu, et võrdub ja siis kuidagi ma ei tea, Kirjutab mingisugust koodi veel. Vaata, on ju? Teed seda meie ees.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on vaja aru, saada, kuidas ta seda meie eest teeb,
Õpetaja: Mis On see programmiline võte, mille abil? Ee, ta tegelikult.
Õpetaja: Ee. Siis teeb selle ära, et seal on nagu niukest kaks osapoolt, et, ee, üks on seotud selle muutujaga endaga ja teine on seotud, et peab olema üks ee tööriist seal niiöelda, mille abil ta siis ee, teeb, teeb plastilist objekte ja väärtistab muutujate muutujatel.
Õpetaja: Niiöelda teisi objekte.
Õpetaja: Ma ei taha nagu väga otseselt siin rohkem.
Õpetaja: Konstruktor
Õpetaja: Mm. Konstruktor on üks võte, et Selles mõttes, et konstruktor on see mehhaaniline võte. Kuidas objekt saab sündida? Kui me teeme sellise konstruktori sinna, mis võtab sisse Atm Location Service objekti,
Õpetaja: siis põhimõtteliselt see konstruktor on Siis ongi ainukene moodus. Kuidas on võimalik objekti teha? On läbi konstruktori. Ja kui see konstruktor on selline, mis võtab sisse just sellise objekti, mis on siin üleval ka muuta, On olemas siis põhimõtteliselt niimoodi saabki Aga siin on üks konks veel
Õpetaja: Muutuja enda juures pidi ka ee erilise sõna niiöelda maha märkima, et see asi nagu kompotina tootab, Millest ma räägin,
Õpetaja: laine
Õpetaja: see on see, Et, Ee, meil on ära markeeritud. Näiteks sellest klassist. No vastavalt oma koodi ka meelde. Tuletuseks on ju, et näiteks selles Controller is see Private
Õpetaja: Atm Location Service nimega Atm Location Service. Kui see on ära markeeritud final, mis tähendab seda, et, ee, see niiöelda
Õpetaja: selle muutuja niiöelda Objekt taustal ei saa kunagi muutuda, et tal saab olla ainult seotud. Üks Ja üksainus objekt ainult ühe korra. Ja see on täpselt sellel Hetkel, kui sellest kontrollerist endast tehakse objekt. Noh, kui vaadata näiteks praegult siin neid sõltuvusi,
Õpetaja: kui näiteks praegult, hakkaks. Praegult. Ee, ütleme niimoodi, et Kui praegult hakkaks Ee. Spring tegema niiöelda objekte
Õpetaja: nendest niiöelda kastidest, siis ta töö praegu töötaks. Ta tagurpidi. Vaata
Õpetaja: Ta ei saa ennem teha Atm Location Controllerist objekti. Sellepärast, et siin on Niukene muutuja, mis viitab Ee objektile,
Õpetaja: et tal on nagu selles mõttes nagu ta ei saa ennem teha seda objekti, kui tal on olemas see objekt. Miks sellepärast, Kui ta teeb nii öelda selle objekti, siis siin on see välja Atm Location Service mille taha, peab tulema Atm Location Service objekt selle muutuja taha.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis järjekorras vaataks, et okei, siis hakkame vaatama Service Service Id. Ta ei saa ka kohe järgmisena teha. Sellepärast, et siin on sõltuvused ja location.
Õpetaja: Järelikult ta kõigepealt üldse näiteks peaks tegema, objekti sellest mäpparklassist.
Õpetaja: Kui siin ei ole sõltuvust. Ühegi te ühestki teisest objektist võib selle objekti valmis.
Õpetaja: Siis tehakse võibolla see objekt valmis. Sellel ei Ole ka sõltuvust millestki. Need kaks objekti on olemas. Siis idee järgi ta saaks teha Atom Location Servicest objekti Sellepärast, et tal on Niukene Konstruktor, mis võtab sisse kaks objekti. Location Objekti ja Location Mapper objekti. Järelikult need peavad olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui ta saab selle tehtud, alles, siis saaks ta tegelikult teha objekti Atm Location Controllerist. Sellepärast, et tal on vaja Atm Location Service objekti.
Õpetaja: Kas te saate mõttest aru, Vaata et siin on nagu selles mõttes sõltuvused.
Õpetaja: Aga Spring suudab meie eest manageerida seda senikaua, kuni me anname talle märku, et me seda tahame ja anname talle tehnilised kõik vajalikud Ee, konstruktorid, mida tema vajab.
Õpetaja: Noh, meil on väga lihtne.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelikult, et kui meie tinglikult võiks siia peale jo kirjutada ühe notatsiooni Sisuliselt veel nendele kahele rest. Controller I alla võiks panna ühe anotatsiooni Ad Service alla võiks vabalt panna veel ühe annotatsiooni.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis annutatsioonist juttu Käib?
Õpetaja: Vihjaks. Aidan seda. Vaata, et Ee Jaova lemmik Saar Mitte Bali.
Õpetaja: Nii, Lomboko on väike vihje, Aga mina küsin teile, et mis annutatsioon võiks kandida? Tegelikult iga Jumala kord vähemalt nendele panna. Sellepärast, et meil on sõltuvust, kellestki teisest
Õpetaja: koer tahaks. Konstruktor on ju, et siis Lombok teab, et kõik need väljad, mis on markeeritud. Niiöelda
Õpetaja: siis ta teeb niukse konstruktori. Vaata, et see sisendina võetakse sisse,
Õpetaja: See vajab konstruktorit. See vajab konstruktorit. Ja, vabandust, ee. Ei vaja rekuertaarskonstruktorit. Miks
Õpetaja: neile nemad ei suhtle Ühegi teise objektiga? Neil ei ole ära Markeeritud siia faili, et ei. Ee palun. Mul on vaja mingisuguse kastiga rääkida,
Õpetaja: et see Service. Vaata, räägib repositoriga. Ee, Service räägib selle mäperiga, Temal on vaja.
Õpetaja: Aga Mäppar ise ei suhtle enam kellegagi. Ja repositori ka. Ei suhtle enam. Tegelikult selles mõttes kellegagi, vähemalt mitte meie programmis,
Õpetaja: Tal ei ole vaja mingi teise repositori või teise service või teise mäppariga. Need uks ei suhtle Ee, selle kokkupanijaga.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga vaatame siis Ee,
Õpetaja: koju.
Õpetaja: Ja just see final Keyword teebki selle
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et seda selle objektile saab ainult siis anda mingit miiningful väärtust,
Õpetaja: kui see objekt ise sünnib. Paneme nüüd koodibaasi ette, et oleks jälle millestki rääkida. Ee, panen siit. Ee, Tulen sellest kontrollerist. Hakkame pihta. Esimene kast.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on väli.
Õpetaja: See mõte on see, et kui me nüüd teeme siia neid, teen igasuguseid teenuseid juurde, siis kõik need teenused.
Õpetaja: Noh, meil on praegu sama nimelised, aga
Õpetaja: et seal tuleb terve posu mingisuguseid veebiteenuseid. Nemad kõik tahavad suhelda kastiga ja seal sees hakkavad. Selles on mingi omakorda Meetodid, millega nemad niiöelda soovivad siis suhelda. Aga siis ongi, et kuidas seda saaks?
Õpetaja: Seda Saab niimoodi, et me kõigepealt markeerime ära selle ee klass selle muutuja, et
Õpetaja: ta on final. Vaata, kui ta ei ole final, siis sa saad seda muuta kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ta on Final, siis tähendab seda, et
Õpetaja: kui tehakse objekt sellest klassist, siis selle loomise hetkel on vaja see asi väärtustada. Noh, ka enda peab juhtuma, See.
Õpetaja: See peab tulema objekt taha.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: ainult sellel hetkel, kui objekt sellest klassist luuakse, on võim. Noh, muidu ma ütlengi, tal on Muidu, kui siia mingit väärtust ei pane ja seda konstruktori pulli ei ole,
Õpetaja: siis tema väike väärtus on
Õpetaja: on all, et lood objekti sellest klassist.
Õpetaja: See on põhimõtteliselt see final tähendab Konstanti.
Õpetaja: Ma olen konstantselt sama, Mis iganes väärtusel ma saan, Seda ei saa muuta enam,
Õpetaja: aga täiesti Kasutu olend oleks seal muutuja,
Õpetaja: kui ta oleks kogu aeg on all. Mis temaga siis teha on? Sama hästi, siis kustuta ära. Kui temaga Mitte midagi ei ole võimalik teha, sest nal ega ei ole tõesti mitte midagi teha. Tõesti, kasuta olend.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga siis ongi see, et, Oot, oot, oot, Kuidas
Õpetaja: tema ütleb ka? Ja vaata siin juba punane pirn, et. Kuule, sul on vaja konstruktorit,
Õpetaja: et see teda initsialiseerita, et Siia objekti ei teki.
Õpetaja: Ütleb, et. Aga Lisa, vaata. Konstruktor selle sama parameetriga,
Õpetaja: palun väga, Keegi ütleb New Loging Controller
Õpetaja: ja nüüd ongi ainult Ainult siis saab seda käivitada seda
Õpetaja: konstruktorid. Kui sa annad siia kaasa, Sa võid ikkagi muidugi ka nal I anda kaasa käivitamisel. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: Ee, see on teine. See on teine asi, Aga põhimõtteliselt seda objekti on võimalik ainult teha läbi selle konstruktori ainult
Õpetaja: siin on nagu kõik või mitte midagi. Hetkel on nagu Pig. Probleem on ju
Õpetaja: nüüd. Siin ongi, et kes iganes ütleb New Logging Controller.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma võin korra teha selle meetodi lihtsalt võtta.
Õpetaja: Ma saaksin koodi kirjutada. Ma saan öelda näiteks, ee. New Log in Service
Õpetaja: vajab ka. Vaata, mida tema vajab. User depositor. It, on ju? Aga see selleks praegult. Kujutame ette, et on, ee,
Õpetaja: noh, kus sa need lapsed siia sisse
Õpetaja: kui meil, on See Login Service olemas.
Õpetaja: Siis ma saan öelda. New Login Controller.
Õpetaja: Ja see on täpselt samamoodi. Vaata täpselt täpselt Niimoodi Kuskil Spring tahab kirjutada Näiteks koodirida.
Õpetaja: Aga ta ei saa muud moodi seda teha,
Õpetaja: kui ainult läbi selle konstruktori, mis on siin
Õpetaja: ja see tähendab seda, et ta Peab andma kaasa
Õpetaja: objekti. Kui tal on see olemas, siis ta annab. Käivitab see meetod.
Õpetaja: Kirjuta kõike samas koodifailis. See on nagu selles mõttes Nagu segadust tekitav
Õpetaja: meile. Ütleme niimoodi, et, ee. Ma saaksin teile lihtsalt pähe raiuda selle. Vaata, et tehke alati lihtsalt niimoodi, et pange alati need muutujad final ja pange siia juurde. Oleks konstruktor. Ee, me saaksime seda niimoodi teha. No see konstruktor tuleb särkustada topelt, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga ma Tahaksin, et te tegelikult ikkagi saate aru, miks.
Õpetaja: Miks see nii on? Miks see on vajalik, kuidas see töötab?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kuidas teised Teiste keelte raamistikud näiteks analoogset asja lahendavad. Aga ma kujutan ette, et kind
Õpetaja: vähemalt objekti orienteeritud programmeerimises.
Õpetaja: Nii, mida meie Intelligence senikaua kuni sina Näed kõikidele klassidele. Näete seda piini siin?
Õpetaja: Noh, selles me arutasime, aga kohe nagu ei tulnud vastusena,
Õpetaja: Kui Kui ei ole neid koodiridu, eelkõige seda ülemist, siis Spring ei tee sellest objekt Ise
Õpetaja: Ta ei tee seda, Aga kui on,
Õpetaja: siis Spring, teeb sellest objekti ja hoiab seda Konteineris meil. On? See kohvipiin märkab.
Õpetaja: Siin on siin ei ole. Vaata, et siin on. Nagu näitab, et. Hei, ee, Minul on kuskil olemas
Õpetaja: Potentsiaalselt objekt, mille Spring saab automaatselt ise ära ühendada. Tal on konteineris.
Õpetaja: Tal on konteineris log in Service objekt. Tema Connect Ib Autowired automaatselt ühendab ära.
Õpetaja: Selle muutuja.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme korra siia kasti. Lihtsalt nagu teeme kasti. Meil on kast.
Õpetaja: Meil on kast. Kus sees on Login Service objekt.
Õpetaja: Nii, tema on nagu siis see. Vaata, et. Aa, Okei, nii mina tean.
Õpetaja: Mina tean, kus see objekt asub. Ma Connect in su Sellega ära
Õpetaja: Saate metsast ära.
Õpetaja: Seal tegelikult on muid objekte ka. Näiteks seal on. Ee.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea.
Õpetaja: Ee, ee, Mis seal oli? Näiteks User
Õpetaja: user repositori näiteks Selline objekt on.
Õpetaja: Näiteks on seal hiljem. Näiteks puser. Mapper objekt.
Õpetaja: Temal on klassikene.
Õpetaja: Temal on kastikene igast erinevatest objektidest
Õpetaja: Ja tema seda tüüpi näeb. See on selle klassi objekt. Kas mul on selle klassi objekt seal konteineris?
Õpetaja: Kui jah, siis ta saab aru, et läbi konstruktori. Kui seda klassi sellest klassist objekti teha siis ta läheb
Õpetaja: väljakutsumisel. New Log in Controller on vaja viidata objektile, Tal on see olemas. Tal on oma mingid viited seal nendele objektidele ja teeb seda meie eest.
Õpetaja: Connequib. Ära tal neid teisi ei ole vaja. Vaata, Teised on nagu teistest On tal tegelikult on savik.
Õpetaja: Saab seda, aga ta teeb seda meie eest.
Õpetaja: Sind ütlevad ka, et on ja nüüd Ongi see, et miks seda service It on vaja.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle service ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd me saame kujutada ette, et siin ei ole enam Piinobjekti enam. Ee, Spring ei tee sellest objektist. Tal on nagu see, et
Õpetaja: kahjuks ühtegi sobivat kandidaati. Seal kastis pole. Konteineris pole niukest objekti Ongi see, et
Õpetaja: siin peab olema see At Service, mis annab ka mingeid muid asju. Aga üks nendest asjadest on see, et siis tehakse Komponent
Õpetaja: Näed, Näete, et komponent on siin peal? On?
Õpetaja: Tegelikult. See on mis? Nagu põhimõtteliselt ütlen, aga pole kunagi lugenud. Vaatan, mis ta ütleb, Selle kaotaja
Õpetaja: räägib hästi niisugusest. Ee High level jutus.
Õpetaja: Noh, Kaine nagu muidugi. Ütleb ära, et
Õpetaja: Such Classes are Considered as Candidates for autodeks Detection.
Õpetaja: Tehniline jutt aga põhimõtteliselt kõigel, millel on peal äkki komponent. Spring teeb automaatselt Kohe
Õpetaja: Ma võin ise ka teha. Näiteks mingisuguse. Ma ei tea mingisuguse. Ma ei tea, ma teen mingi imeliku klassi.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me tahaks läbi objekti orienteeritud kuju teha mingi utiliti näiteks, ma tahaksin seda
Õpetaja: mingil põhjusel, et mul on läbi objekti. Mõistlikum. Oleks niukest asja teha päriselt otse läbi staatilise meetodiga vahet. Pole ma, Saan näiteks teha Ät Komponent
Õpetaja: tuli oma märk ja tehakse sellest objekt. Seda komponentit ei kasuta kunagi nagu tata tüüpi objektidel nagu student, vaata,
Õpetaja: Sellepärast et su Point on see, et siin on ainult üks objekt. Sellest. Üks objekt konteineris. Kui sa tahad seda data konverterit. Vabandust,
Õpetaja: see on seal nii Pea, kui ma tegin niimoodi võime mõelda jälle. Vaata, et näed, siin kastis on.
Õpetaja: Meil on veel üks objekt
Õpetaja: parematest aru
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, ee, Kui me nüüd vaatame seda.
Õpetaja: Meil on olemas markeeritud väli, mis on?
Õpetaja: Meil on Lomboki poolt. Näete, Lombok.
Õpetaja: Lomboki Poolt Ee Lombok teeb konstruktori selle meie eest ise ära
Õpetaja: siin ei ole. No ma võin. Ma ei tea, kas mul kuskil koodis praegu viga on või mitte,
Õpetaja: see On see korra Roll Back in Lihtsalt siin ikka on.
Õpetaja: Pack in
Õpetaja: Kuskil viga pole. Et. Ee, kui mina praegult.
Õpetaja: Kas siin, kui ma Vaatan seda. Login Controller It. Kas siin on praegult Ee, konstruktorid, mis võtab sisse
Õpetaja: on või ei, ole, ei, ole. Kui Ma panen selle käima korra, et lihtsalt pilditakse. Pildimine huvitab eelkõige.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen nüüd out class I,
Õpetaja: Mitte out class, I vaid outkataloogi mis on siis teinud. Tulen Otsin selle Ülesse Channereid, et on
Õpetaja: markeeritakse ära ka, et Final Final täida ära,
Õpetaja: aga siin on isegi ka see kuvatakse, et Piinobjekt lahendatakse.
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, Action It ei tee
Õpetaja: Me lihtsalt, ee. Põhimõtteliselt. Mis iganes informatsioon tuleb meil veebist sisse elab siin selles
Õpetaja: muutujast login. Request. Noh, internetist tuleb siis Jasonina Username Password.
Õpetaja: Kuid käivitub ainukene moodus. Kuidas see asi käivitatakse. Ongi see, et
Õpetaja: kuna siin on ät Rest Controller siis dispatser teab, Kui tuleb lisasõnum appi. Login Post
Õpetaja: ei pea. Ei login. Siis ta teab, et ta käivitab meetodi Login, user, mis asub Login Controller klassis. Aga
Õpetaja: meie oleme veel öelnud, et et kui sa käivitad selle meetodi,
Õpetaja: siis siia, on vaja niukest objekti nagu Login Request.
Õpetaja: Ole hea, anna see mulle. Aga me oleme vihjeks öelnud ka, et kui sa selle siis petseri info saab,
Õpetaja: Noh, kujutame ette siis Nagu Kainda, Nagu, noh, mingi telegramme. Äkki vä
Õpetaja: keegi. Keegi. Ee. Helistab dispetšerile ja ütleb et Kuule,
Õpetaja: ole Ole hea. Saada telegram sõnumiga, saada sõnumiga. Minu kasutajanimi. Parool
Õpetaja: Ei tea, miks peaks seda tegema nagu tavakõnes, Aga Okei,
Õpetaja: siis ongi see, et see nüüd on, siis see on Request Bodies on nüüd tata.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd, mis läheb kaasa. Vaata ja mis on vaja. Nagu selles tegevuses,
Õpetaja: et dispetšer siis teab, et Okei, et
Õpetaja: see username ja oleks ka vaja kaasa anda. Mina sain selle. Ma ei tea ee inimeselt Kas siis verbaalselt või ta andis mulle mingi kirjapaberi.
Õpetaja: Aga mina, igal juhul, kui käivitan selle tegevuse, siis ma panen selle info niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Noh, kasvõi ümbrikuna kaasa, näiteks on ümbrikuski See on siis,
Õpetaja: ee. Mingid ee väärtustega midagi. Tahaks Nüüd see tuleb siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Minu mõte, et kui me jõuame siia, siis me käivitame Uue tegevuse.
Õpetaja: See asi. Nüüd viiakse see tegevus
Õpetaja: teise klassi ära viiakse loogiline Service ära.
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: see, et siin, me viitame sellele sildile, tähendab, et see objekt, Mis iganes me saame dispetšerservati, et me anname nüüd ise ka kaasa.
Õpetaja: Päris taustal. Me ei anna isegi objekti, vaid anname Hoopis, mille me anname kaasa, kui hästi teenis minna
Õpetaja: mälukoha. Lihtsalt jah, et nagu tegelikult, see on nagu, ülimalt. Ee, kiire. Ee, on see programm. Tänu sellele, et tegelikult siin mingisugused andmete mõttes. Mingid andmed ei liigu siin erinevate koodi osade, vahel
Õpetaja: vaid lihtsalt mäluviited nendele andmetele. Nii on palju kiirem.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui mõelda, nagu et see oleks nagu päriselt. Nagu et viska objekt sisse ja teine püüab objekti kinni. Noh, kui See näiteks mingi
Õpetaja: pildifail Pildifail. Sul Hoopis mingi muusikafail või videofail?
Õpetaja: Päris suured suured andmed on tegelikult taustal. Mis siis peaksid liikuma?
Õpetaja: Noh, aga Siis olekski nagu. Et kui iga koodi osa, nagu päriselt ka enda, annaks edasi mingi gigabaidist asja. Vaata, siis, see asi vist väga kiire poleks. Tegelikult on siis see, et lihtsalt antakse, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: see video, see video, see video, see video, Nagu, et viide sellele
Õpetaja: midagi taolist. Noh, mingi niuke analoogia.
Õpetaja: No meil nüüd siin. Jõuamegi nüüd siia Teise kasti.
Õpetaja: Login Service on siin. Ad Service peal.
Õpetaja: Konstruktor on peal.
Õpetaja: On meil sõltuvus mingisugusest järgmisest kastist. Noh, see on meie uks.
Õpetaja: Kuus uks viib meid.
Õpetaja: Kuhu hoidlasse see uks viib.
Õpetaja: Noh, Näed välja, mis sa Räägid seal,
Õpetaja: aga täpsemalt andmed on ikka väga geneeriline. Ma võiksin siis öelda. Lausa siin, tata nagu
Õpetaja: kasutajaandmed Aga räägime veel täpsemalt. Me teame tegelikult Kuhu see tee viib meid?
Õpetaja: No okei, nüüd juba vähemalt tuli see üks sõna. Üks sõna tuli see tabel.
Õpetaja: Nüüd räägime veel täpsemalt. Kuhu Viib user?
Õpetaja: Okei, depositori
Õpetaja: voh. Jaroslav. Mis sa ütlesid Hussaari tabelisse. See on uks pusertabelisse. Palun väga kõik
Õpetaja: Thats It nii lihtne see ongi?
Õpetaja: See. See on uks. Susertabelisse Tuleb meelde Supihoidla. Uks.
Õpetaja: Magusahoidla. Uks Ee. Mis seal veel oli? Burksihoidla uks.
Õpetaja: Iga see asi, et supiga On üks tabel
Õpetaja: Ee magusad asjad on üks tabel.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis seal veel oli?
Õpetaja: Buršid seal olid erinevad buršid. Andmed on erinevad. Noh, tiramiisu Millest tema koosneb.
Õpetaja: Millest koosneb veiseliha ports.
Õpetaja: Mingid teised burgerid ka. Aga kõik on burgerid. Kõik on burgerid, kõik on supid, kõik on mingid Magustoidud. Need on lihtsalt konkreetselt ühe temaatilised
Õpetaja: andmed user, andmed, City andmed, rolli andmed.
Õpetaja: Ja see repositori on lihtsalt uks. Ja kui ma. Küsin seda, kuhu Vaata siis konkreetse Tabeli vastu. Kui ma küsin konkreetselt, et kui sa repositori,
Õpetaja: mis tema meile annab või või mis, mis ta on Siis see on user Tabelis, see on. See on meie uks. Usertabelisse. Muud moodi ei ole. Vaata, ei, ole, ei ole lihtsalt geneerilised Andmed ei ole andmed, Sest et ta ei ole üldine.
Õpetaja: See klass ei ole seotud kogu andmebaasiga, vaid konkreetse andmebaasi konkreetse tabeliga.
Õpetaja: See user Depositor. Kui me läheme sinna sisse, on seotud konkreetse entitiga.
Õpetaja: Entity. Mis asi on Entity?
Õpetaja: Mis on Entity klass, mis on tema eesmärk,
Õpetaja: ei Tee tabelist objekti. See on veits vale.
Õpetaja: Noh, Data. Obk. Aga vaata see sõna. Tabel on praegu vale.
Õpetaja: Ta ei tee tabelist objekti.
Õpetaja: Vot Tubli, jälle. Lähme täpsemalt.
Õpetaja: See klass on mõeldud selle, jaoks, et sellest saab teha kasvõi tuhat objekti. Aga üks objekt
Õpetaja: hoiab konkreetse tabeli ühe Rea andmeid. Ühe rea andmeid.
Õpetaja: See ei ole Tabeli objekt.
Õpetaja: Sul on tabelirea tegelikult.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma vaatan nagu täpsemalt, vaata onju, et kui. Ma ütlen, et mis see user Entity on. Siis võiks öelda, et sa näete. Tabel on siin Olemas See on Usr tabel, Ma klikin siia peale. Mis juhtub
Õpetaja: Põmm Intellisi database. Mis ta lahti tegi?
Õpetaja: Panen uuesti kinni. Nagu Panen kinni Mis ta teeb lahti puseritabeli, kui Siin on veerg.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, Staatus.
Õpetaja: Kui ma klikin siia, ma panen kinni, mis juhtub.
Õpetaja: Oota siin, Columname I peale klikkima siia.
Õpetaja: Mis ta tegi lahti, User Tabeli
Õpetaja: veeru staatus. No ma praegu näen, et see on ikkagi. Läks kõik siin järjekord valesti. Ma jätan selle It ette, Genereerin korra uuesti.
Õpetaja: Seda teeks õiges järjekorras.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on õiges järjekorras Samas järjekorras nagu tabelis,
Õpetaja: Saate aru, See on üks rida. Kas nüüd on arusaadav. See See tegelikult ei ole midagi väga keerulist. See on ju kõik selle sama. Ee, analoogiaga nagu seal restoranis on ju, et See oli üks konkreetse. Ee, Niiöelda asja
Õpetaja: lattu purksid supid, magustoidud, user, andmed. City andmed, location andmed profile, andmed, transaction type andmeid, erinevad andmed Okei,
Õpetaja: ei, eraldi, Aitäh on sellepärast. Data S on, ee, üks
Õpetaja: ee. Meetod, mis meile ei meeldi. Siin kontekstis
Õpetaja: juba ulub ka. Vaata, its Not recommended. Ee, sellepärast, et meil võib olla tõsiseid mäluprobleeme võib tekitada.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaadake, see Tehnoloogia on tehtud niimoodi, et ta ise manageerib meie ees Seda, et kuidas ta nagu sealt andmeid Ee, siia objektidesse otsib. Eriti kui meil on sõltuvus teistes tabelites. Meil on,
Õpetaja: et ee sellega on Niimoodi et kui mina küsin, näiteks ee, tuhat rida. Vaata, user tabelist.
Õpetaja: Ja mul tegelikult ei olegi kordagi vaja, mis on
Õpetaja: tema suudab automaatiliselt meie eest. Tegelikult otsida ka igale objektile roll tabelis panna.
Õpetaja: Aga ta ei tee seda vaikenisi. Siis on Vaadake, siin on. Siin on Niukene. Ee, asi. Nagu Too andmeid on ära määratud. Laisy variandid On Lazy ja Eager. Mis on? Mis on Eager?
Õpetaja: Raisk? Usin.
Õpetaja: Kui on leising, siis tähendab seda, et kui tema otsib sada rida user tabelist, siis vaikimisi. Kui kuskil koodis selle role I poole ei pöörduta, siis Ta ei viitsi neid andmeid Too ära tuua sellest. Ee, tema mõte on see, et tal on selles tabelis. Tegelikult
Õpetaja: Siin on lihtsalt number. Me jõuame seda. Ma hakkan ka jääppima. Siin. Ee, siin on. Numbrid On, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga siin. Ee, selles Jpa S. Ei ole meil siin vaid hoopis siin. Hoiame kogu Role objekti. Ja tema mõte on, see et kui sa soovid ja sul on vaja, siis ta lihtsalt kasutab seda sama numbrit, mis tal siis väärtusena on?
Õpetaja: Ja ta läheb ise toob ära selle numbriga
Õpetaja: konkreetse rea objekti. Noh, näiteks kaks võtab Kogu selle rea
Õpetaja: ja ta ise tuleb, teeb. Otsib andmed, pärib
Õpetaja: ja paneb siia, selle rolli külge
Õpetaja: Aga ta ei tee seda iga Jumala, kord
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et meil on ära määratud, et et ainult siis, kui meil on tegelikult vaja. Kui me hakkame koodis kuskile viitama sellele roolile Mingi hetk meil on objekt useris. Ta läheb alles. Siis toob selle ära. Esialgu ta ei kavatse tuua seda ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Miks äpp data Siia Ei, sobi on see, et siin on näiteks Niukene meetod. Nagu Too string
Õpetaja: Ee meetod. Meetod. No tegelikult on teised asjad asjad seal Koodi tasandil on juba viited sellele objektile, mis tähendas seda, et kui meil on siin tool string on juures
Õpetaja: selles meetodist, siis ta tegelikult See meisi selles mõttes ei tööta. Ee, et ta igakord siis tahabki
Õpetaja: tuua Vaata Niipea, kui koodis on viidatud rahule objektile
Õpetaja: selle protsessi käigud, Vaata, user andmed. Kui on kuskil koorilõik, mis viitab niiöelda Roole objektile. Siis Ta toob ära andmed Rooli ajaks ka aga tee, useris String representatsioon
Õpetaja: siis nagu oleks nagu see.
Õpetaja: Kuule, aga siis on ju sellele ta viitabki Ta ütleb seda. Vaata, et ma võin selle data siit ära võtta ja panen hoopis ring ät.
Õpetaja: Siis ta ütlebki. Kuule, aga see asi teeb, ee,
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt ütleb nagu seda, et nüüd enam ei Ole niimoodi et sa võtad need andmed ja esialgu seda leisi värki ei tõmba. Sellepärast, et viitab väljale role, mis teeb sellest automaatselt
Õpetaja: nõutud välja, nagu ütleme. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kaks läheb iga rea kohta.
Õpetaja: Üks. No mitte, Kaks eeskuju päringut Vaata selles mõttes userit saab juba näiteks Listina. Iga Rea kohta, mis? Tema leiab andmebaasis. Ta peab tegema ühe ekstra, Päringu tabeli vastu
Õpetaja: jätkub.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: aitäh.
Õpetaja: Seda Ei, oleks
Õpetaja: sul ei olegi seal Ja kohe sees. Ee, su. Sul on ta ainult siis sees. Vaata, kui sa pöördud selle rolle objekti poole ja roole objekti enda sees On see Id olemas? Aga ja user is. Vaata, ei ole. Alati on võimalik teha ka juurde niukest. Varianti on ka võimalik teha, et sa teed? Noh, seda saab teha, et ühtlasi on olemas. Siin
Õpetaja: Integer Role Id. Ütlen, et see on. Ee.
Õpetaja: Ma Ei, tea. Noh, see Selleks. Vaata, join I. Ma ei tee, vaid. Ma lihtsalt määran Columni nime. At Column,
Õpetaja: Name ja Columny Name on see sama role Id,
Õpetaja: et ma saaksin, kui ma tahaksin. Ma saaksin siin ka tegelikult mõlemaid hoida.
Õpetaja: Ja selleks ei ole absoluutselt vajalikku.
Õpetaja: See, on, ee, mugavustehnoloogia see on läbi ja lõhki Mugavustehnoloogia.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on See Mugavus Ongi see, et kui andmed on omavahelis relatsiooniliselt niiöelda seotud
Õpetaja: siis ee, kui meie Pärime mingi ühe tabeli andmeid. Ja seal on,
Õpetaja: ee, niiöelda teistele tabelitele. Siis juhul kui me pöördume nende niiöelda objektide poole, mis on niiöelda Need seo seostabelid need teised tabelid. Teine rida. Kui me pöördume nende poole, vaata siis tehnoloogia taustal ise meie eest ja
Õpetaja: nagu pidid midagi kirjutama nagu null koodi rida
Õpetaja: Kui ma küsin andmeid. Ee, kui ma. Kui ma ei puuduta neid porengiivisi, siis neid ei tõmmata. Kui ma Puudutan neid porengi, siis neid tõmmatakse.
Õpetaja: Tähendab, sellel hetkel, kui ma pöördun enda poole.
Õpetaja: Seda peab ka teadma. Näiteks ma ütlengi. Näiteks saadki teha ka vigu. Vaata, kus asjatult. Võibolla kompad mingisugust objekti, mida sa tegelikult väga ikkagi ei vaja ja ei kasuta. Vaata, onju, aga siis tänu sellele nii öelda läheb taustal niiöelda päring. Kohe vaatame ka neid. Mul on siin Niukene väikene seadistus peale tehtud
Õpetaja: väike spioon, kes pioneerib niiöelda igat andmebaasi pärimust ja me näeme, mis päringud lähevad teele.
Õpetaja: Need ei ole kirjutatud nagu väga inimsõbralikud, aga printsiibis Ee on need päringud tegelikult arusaadavad Ja vähemalt niiöelda võimalik on neid ee, kuvada ja Skl Ina Ta ise jooksutada. Niiöelda pärast räägime sellest,
Õpetaja: Aga see põhiline asi on See. See on taotluslik. Vaata aga, meie seda klassi ei teinud. On ju
Õpetaja: Ee, Jpa tegi selle klassi sellisena, nagu ta arvas, et see Kõige Mõistlikum oleks sellel. Hetkel pakub ka mingeid ja võimalusi kus, me saame sättida asju kui, me tahame kuidagi teistmoodi aga, Default Satted tekitasid meile sellise klassi. Miks, Sest et nii See oleks kõige mõistlikum
Õpetaja: kui, siia panna näiteks Selle ee kohta mitte laisy Vaid, eager
Õpetaja: Siis. On Niimoodi, et sa küsid Sada rida user tabelis iga rea kohta. Ta ei hakka isegi vaatama, kas sa programmiliselt pöördud kuskil selle väljapoole või Mitte ta nii, kui nii
Õpetaja: ta innukas ta läheb, pärib kohe need andmed.
Õpetaja: Aga see on kõik mugavustehnoloogia. Kohe jõuame nüüd ju ka repositori juurde, kus me vaatame, kuidas me saame päringuid andmebaase teha. Vanasti pidi panema
Õpetaja: Tee loo. Database. Connection E. Connection. Tee Nüüd pärit. Pane see Vaata, siit võib ka mingi viga tulla. Mida iganes siis
Õpetaja: siis peab tulema kuskilt muutujast sise, sest ring lõpeb. Parameetrid ja asjad vanasti pidi tegema mingit päris palju fookuspookust,
Õpetaja: et saada kätte. See on alles esimene pool. Nüüd andmed tulevad.
Õpetaja: On nagu, Noh Ütleme, et tulevad siis nagu, Noh, teile võibolla kõige lihtsam mõelda. Stringina. Kuidas me sellest objekti saame? Me peame hakkama progema seda. Vaata, mul tuleb mingisugune info teatud kujul. Ma pean hakkama seda näppima ja programmeerima, et kuidas tuleb. Jaavas Just selline? Objekt. Nagu näiteks user.
Õpetaja: Noh, kõike seda Staffi pidi vanasti nagu Ise käisid seda tegema.
Õpetaja: Midagi ei pea tegema enam. Nagu. Sest et seda ei ole mõtet. Selle mõte on see, et see see oli kogu aeg Boiler play, et tegelikult sul on kogu aeg ühetaoline kood uuesti ja uuesti ja uuesti uuesti väikeste muudatustega
Õpetaja: Ka Springpoodi. Enda mõte on praegu. Jätame korra kõrvale.
Õpetaja: Kõik need asjad, mis siin on, et mingi veebiteenused ja asjad, et paned. Siin on notatsioon. Seal on notatsioon, See on mugavus, lihtsus, loetavus. Kõik on nagu ühes
Õpetaja: lihtsamaks, sest et vaniljaamas. Kui vanasti neid asju tegid, siis kogu aeg mingi sama rütmiga Kood koguaeg, kordus uuesti uuesti, uuesti uuesti väikeste variatsioonidega.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ongi see raamistik lahendab meie ees selle ära, et sa ei pea kogu aeg Kirjutama seda sama mõttekat koodi tuhandet korda uuesti. Täpselt sama mustriga.
Õpetaja: Sest et teeb, selle sinu eest ära.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: jah ma ütlen ka, et Ega see, see, et siin on üldse Jp, on kasutusel. See ei tule kuskilt nagu lampi. See see tuleb, et me oleme öelnud, et Me soovime seda, kui me otsime ülesse siin Back endist
Õpetaja: faili.
Õpetaja: See siin ütleb, et me üldse soovime sellist lähenemist.
Õpetaja: See siin ütleb, et Me soovime kasutada.
Õpetaja: See siin ütleb, et soovime kasutada lombokeid.
Õpetaja: See On siin selline väike spioon, et me saame lauseid näha ka päris parameetrite väärtusega väike spioon.
Õpetaja: Mis räägib hiljem.
Õpetaja: Lähme edasi. Ee, Kuhugi peab jõudma ka, Eksole Vastav. Mingi esimene paus peale. Pole ridagi. Koodi kirjutanud.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Ee, panen siin Close Old Tabs,
Õpetaja: et, ee, see repositor ise
Õpetaja: tehniliselt ütleb, et Hei, meie enda kirjutatud fail, aga meil on kõik oskused, Mis on jprositoril
Õpetaja: ja kaasa anname niiöelda selle ühe klassi objekti, mille järgi ta teab
Õpetaja: üldse nagu, et okei, kui ma tahan mingit päringut koostada,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, mis tabel? Mis on Tabeli nimi?
Õpetaja: Ja Mis veerud seal on?
Õpetaja: Tahate mõttest aru?
Õpetaja: Saab kätte ka tüübid, Palun, väga Saab teada, kus on
Õpetaja: nüüd. Eile me jõudsime siis nii kaugele. Kus me siis õppisime? Mis See interface on? Hästi lihtsustatud kujul, mis võiks, öelda, Mis asi ta on,
Õpetaja: Kavand?
Õpetaja: Noh, kavand. Üks parem sõna on veel õige. Teel olev blueprint Eesti keeles.
Õpetaja: Maailm
Õpetaja: Ee Interface oli mall. Tegime Seal Siis selle Animal näite. Vaata onju, et Animal, mis iganes, ee, et kõik loomad toogia kätt ja mina ei tea, mis iganes, et Kes iganes, nagu ütleb, et mina juhindun sellest mallist, siis peabki juhindama sellest mallist. Ee, peamine mõte on meetod
Õpetaja: tegevused.
Õpetaja: Me kirjeldame ära tegevuse Kus peavad olema.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis puudutab siis ee, koodi osas? Ee, siis. Mis vahe oli seal? Kui me tegime Animal Interface, Me tegime meetodi. Meil näiteks oli toob. Ja siis meil oli sama meetod, mis Seal oli suur vahe. Vaata, et kui vaadata kahte koodifaili,
Õpetaja: mitte erinev, kui Me räägime konkreetselt. Me Ei, räägi. Praegu. Kätte toob. Me räägime. Animal. Mis on blueprint ja too, Mis on implementatsioon, kui vaadata neid nende Kahte meetrit, mis on nagu oli. Mis seal on suur erinevus
Õpetaja: Animalil midagi pole. Ja. Ja dogil. Näiteks midagi seal. Siis selles meetodis on põhimõtteliselt ära ketta.
Õpetaja: Jah, sisu.
Õpetaja: Nii, mis seal sisulga on?
Õpetaja: Ei ole Ja Interpace Il ei ole meetodi sisu. Tal ei ole koodiklokki, tal pole skoope.
Õpetaja: Seal on lihtsalt öeldud, et mida sa tagastad?
Õpetaja: Mis on meetodi? Ja mis tüüpi objekt seal meetodil sees käib,
Õpetaja: aga mitte mingit Action It ei ole seal nende asjadega. Ainult see,
Õpetaja: mida see meetod tagastab. Mis on meetode nimi, mida meetod sisse võtab, Ainult kolm osa käib kõik.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, kui seal. Ee, siis keegi kes niiöelda sellest mallist juhindub nüüd seda probleemi peabki lahendama. Mida iganes see meetod ütleb, Vaata, mida ta tegema peab. Siis peabki olema selles niiöelda implementatsiooni. Niiöelda. Ee, klassis peabki olema. Siis see meetod nii öelda. Ära realiseeritud ehk Implementeeritud
Õpetaja: Ehk Kui sul on seal meetod, mis on Void ja Make Noise, siis see meetod peaks seal sees siis tegema midagi
Õpetaja: ma ei tea selles kontekstis, et. Noh, meil oli seal Koer oli midagi taolist. See oli teine meetod, et tagastab stringi ja viib ja võtab sisse Stringi Neil oli näiteks Niukene. Asi onju?
Õpetaja: Pidime tegema niukse meetodi, mis käivitudes Ee, võttis sisse Food I. Näiteks, onju oli See seal mingi Või mis iganes. Ja siis ta pidi lõpuks tagastama Stringi. Nagu et mis? Ta. Nagu. Kuidas ta reageeris sellele toidule. Vaata, onju mingi niuke värk.
Õpetaja: Vot täpselt nimi ongi Nüüd, mis on vaja nagu siin märgata. Vaata, et see ongi Interface.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt kui meie oma näites tegime sellist asja, Vaata kus me tegime nii interface kui ka implementatsiooniklassi.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja niimoodi tehakse. Ka Tegin talle ka. Näite. Mingi payment processor, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Instant Payment processor, näiteks. Ee. Vaata, et see on tavaline võte. Ee Niiöelda arhitektuuris lihtsalt pannakse paika. Vaata, et meil on mingid niuksed, tegevused nihukeste asjade juures. Mitu erinevat vahet.
Õpetaja: Kogu aeg tuleb ajas uurida lahendusi. Siis nad peavad kõik implementeerima seda ühte konkreetset asja ja garanteerima kõik Meetodid on seal nagu ühel või teisel viisil kirjeldatud.
Õpetaja: Aga mis on siin, on nagu, see, et
Õpetaja: siin meid tegelikult on see, et meie Lihtsalt kirjutame interface is Malli.
Õpetaja: Aga Jpa teeb taustal jooksu ajal selle koodi lahenduse ise.
Õpetaja: Me teeme siin selle animeeli ise,
Õpetaja: aga tooge ka kätte meie idee.
Õpetaja: Toogi või käti teeb raamistik ja Jp. Ise
Õpetaja: Miks meile meeldib? Ongi, see et me ei tahagi teha seda? Ee, seda asja. Vaata, etabase Connection. Nüüd tuleb Eschool i lause. Nüüd tuleb mingisugune sisend. Me peame veel vaatama Ee, sisendi poole, et äkki siin ei Ole mingit ründefekt, et äkki siin on mingid lubamatud tähemärgid sees. Nagu
Õpetaja: kogu see staff. Nagu see, see tegevus, mis siin praegult on, on Päris, ee, päris kompleksne,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Ma annan sulle kolm sisendit. Sina otsid tegelt. See on veel lihtne. Seda tuleb üks rida, on ju Aga printsiibis tegelikult taustal teeb päris palju Action E nagu koodi mõttes. Päris koodi mõttes. Aga meid see ei huvita
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et meie lihtsalt Kirjutame praegu siin interface. Lihtsalt malli. Aga me kirjutame seda täpselt selliselt, nagu see tehnoloogia ootab.
Õpetaja: Siin on Niukene sõna nagu Fine seal viitab Kohe objektile. User, seal on sõna. Bye,
Õpetaja: Me viitame väljadele. Mis on? Need on? Välja nimed siin. Kõik, Vaadake, need on kõik väljanimed, mis on Entity klassis. Kas meil on user? Name, Lähme vaatame. On username on.
Õpetaja: Kas meil on siin? Ee, on.
Õpetaja: Kas meil on staatus?
Õpetaja: Noh, on.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast tema teab, et juhul kui me kirjutame need sõnad kõik õigesti,
Õpetaja: tema saab siit kõik info kätte.
Õpetaja: Tabeli nimi Skeema, mida iganes Tema oskab selle meetodi nime järgi ise teha lause.
Õpetaja: Ta oskab ise programmeerida kogu selle koha ära, et kus kõik need sisemid, mis tulevad, Ta vaatab automaatselt. Ära Ega seal ei ole mingit semi koolonid, mis tahab teha Injection It. Mäletate see auto näide Top database, on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: läbi pealt nagu sama Kama. Ta ise teeb selle ära. Ta ise teeb Connection I. Ta ise paneb Connection I kinni
Õpetaja: kogu, et Kui ta lõpuks saab andmed kätte. Ta ise manageerib seda, et konstruktori. Või ta teeb selle userobjekti valmis.
Õpetaja: Võtab oma andmetest sealt. Mis andmebaasis tuleb, teeb sellise objekti.
Õpetaja: Kogu see staff on tehtud meie eest. J Pay ga J. P. Jah
Õpetaja: Ehitaja kohapeal. Midagi automaatselt Mustrid väljas, et Aga ma võtsin enda meetodiga, nii et see on minu meelega.
Õpetaja: Jõuame Selleni saab saab meet ma rääkisin ka, seda et see on mingi Väga kole ja rõve asi. Viimane asi, mis ma eile ütlesin, et Miks peab. Nagu Niukene Staff siin olema? Vaata, kui kain ta, nagu Ma kustutaks selle osa ära.
Õpetaja: Fine user by.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui see neid oleks arusaadav,
Õpetaja: aga praegu on lihtsalt see, et okei, ta ei vasta Enam sellele mustrile, on ju? Ja saab
Õpetaja: Ja teemegi. Ei tahagi. Niimoodi. See On alles esimene step.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, nüüd, mis ma võiks korra teha. See on kaasategevuse koht. See asi peaks olema nähtav. Siis miinimum, kui te olete. Jah,
Õpetaja: laiendab Ee.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, saad õigesti aru. Ainult Ee, mõni sõna. Võibolla läks natukene vales järjekorras. Mitte Jpa repositori. Ei, la ee. Tähendab okei,
Õpetaja: Mitte mitte ei laienda seda user depositor I Vaid selles mõttes. Vastupidi, Userrepositor. Ei, Laienday. Repositor I
Õpetaja: Vaadake, Ee Jpa. Hakkame vaatama korra. Teeme seda see on vaatamise koht. Kui mina teen jpositori lahti ja kasutan Structure tööriista. Ja siin füüsikali peal
Õpetaja: on kõik need meetodid, mis hetkel on kirjas Flush save, Flash save all and Flash Delete Kõik asjad, onju?
Õpetaja: See nüüd tähendab seda, et sellel user repositor Il
Õpetaja: on olemas. Kõik need meetodid, mis on siin, ma võtan Mingi imeliku asja on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui mina lähen sinna sisse.
Õpetaja: Kui mina, lähen Log In Servicesse ja ma viitan user repositorile uue Kui mina Nüüd kirjutan
Õpetaja: siis. Selline meetod on olemas. Delete all in Patch on nii.
Õpetaja: Minu pärandil on see meetod olemas? Järelikult user. Repositoril on see meetod ka olemas.
Õpetaja: Nii Vaatame seda natukene edasi kui me vaatame seda.
Õpetaja: Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, nada. Jah, No tuli tagasi. Tuli tagasi.
Õpetaja: Nii siin on. Ma ei tea mingi kümme meetodit või mis iganes vahet pole on nii
Õpetaja: nüüd. J, P, Repositori.
Õpetaja: Tema Sees on Siin meetodeid on nii.
Õpetaja: Need Flash Saywall. Kõik, mis siin loetles, on need olemas. Siin voodi failis.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd öeldakse, seda, et Jpa repositori omakorda,
Õpetaja: et see kõik need meetodid, mis on siin defineeritud.
Õpetaja: Temal on omakorda olemas. Kõik need meetodid, mis on, mis on ja mis on query. By example executoril
Õpetaja: see. Tähendab seda et, vaata et, tema nagu pärend
Õpetaja: ja. Ta on nagu tema tal. On noh. See, on nagu Veits, veits, imelik. Vaata, tal on kolm pärandit. No meil kõigil on ainult kaks, on ju? Sest me oleme inimesed,
Õpetaja: Aga klassidel saab olla Nagu ta laiendab. Vaata, see laiendab, et tal on kõik omadused olemas. Mis on nendel,
Õpetaja: kui me vaatame,
Õpetaja: See on nagu. Vaata niimoodi user Repositoril on olemas kõik o omadused. Mis on, J. Paul olemas? Kõik omadused. Mis on repositoril? Jällegi, Kui ma. Siit võibolla
Õpetaja: ma ei saa siin. Ee, vist. Ee fold Ida, Aga ma saan jälle vaadata, et siin on mingisugused meetodid. Siin ei ole väga palju meetodeid, aga vaatame, Korra
Õpetaja: siin. On kolm meetodit. Fine Tall on siin.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et kui userrepositoril. Ee, on see tähendab, seda et see sama ee Find all ja save all. Meetodid on olemas ka userrepositoril, et kui mina ütlen siin userrepositori
Õpetaja: punkt, mis asi see oli? Find All vist Oli vä Fine Pann. Tool oli,
Õpetaja: kui ma klikin siia ma panen kinni. Vaata enda paremalt. Kuhu ma kukun?
Õpetaja: Minu on selline meetod, Järelikult on mul ka. Noh, meil kõigil on ee, Dna D oma esivanemates. Neil on võibolla nende juuste värv. Noh, see ei ole nüüd niimoodi garanteeritud kujul. Aga võibolla meil on nende juuste värv.
Õpetaja: Meie pikkus on ka enne nagu seesama. Vaata, on Ju ee, Noh, see et meil on kõigil kaks kätt. Vaata, see on nagu juba läheb väga kaugele. Aadam ja Eva, Vaata, on ju. Meil oli kaks. Kätt. Vaata, need Omadused on meil kõigil. On ju? Kui väga kaugele minna. Aga meil on silmavärvus ja kõik muud. Asjad. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd kui muidugi edasi minna. Vaata, et sellel postitoril on ainult need meetodid ja nii edasi mingid.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd vaatame sellist. Ee, Temal on omakorda omakorda Pärineb temalt Mingisugused asjad tuleb meelde. Noh, ei mõelnud ise välja. Seda agronüümi
Õpetaja: on niuksed. Meetodid, mis tegelevad juba üksikobjektidega.
Õpetaja: Ee, vist Vaata, ma ei teagi tegelikult.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei ole, See on tegevustega. See veel ei ole tingimata, aga siin on näiteks Niukene meetod. Nagu
Õpetaja: Count, näiteks Count on võtame. See on mingi väga eriline Count.
Õpetaja: Kui mina tulen tagasi siia sellesse, ütlen, et Hei puuduta userrepositorit ja, noh, ja panen punkt Count
Õpetaja: on selline meetod olemas,
Õpetaja: kui ma jällegi panen kõik paremalt poolt kinni ja et oleks aja lahti, kui ma võitan kliki, kuhu ma Kukun on nii,
Õpetaja: Aga kui me vaatame seda, siis me vaatame, et tema tavalist repositorid. See on nüüd kõikide repositoride ema,
Õpetaja: kui nii võib öelda.
Õpetaja: Siin Enam mingisugust meetodit pole. Aga see on mingi tehniline Vahet pole. See tähendab seda. Ja siin me praegu tulime. Nüüd nagu niimoodi, Tulime siit userist. Kus me tulime, Jpositor is. Maksime siia suunas minema, Aga on ka. See on ju
Õpetaja: mis siin on Siin on mingi Find all. Asjad tema oleks tendinud midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Siin on jälle mingid meetodid ja lahendused.
Õpetaja: Meil on kõik asjad olemas, aga nüüd me jõuame Nagu selle tuumani. Nagu see põhiline asi on see, mis meid huvitab.
Õpetaja: Userrepositooril on olemas kõik need oma pärandi omadused, aga ta veel extendib, Tuleb uusi omadusi juurde.
Õpetaja: See ongi uus omadus.
Õpetaja: Üks Uus tegevus.
Õpetaja: Find user by username and password and status
Õpetaja: vot. See on see. See on selle asja võti. See on, mis meid tegelikult huvitab.
Õpetaja: Meil on kõik olemas, Mis on, Ütleme niimoodi. Ma hakkan seda Kutsuma. Out of The Box. Vaata, mis tuleb tootega kaasa
Õpetaja: meetodeid, Aga meie saame teha juurde asju. See. On see We are extending puser. Repositori pikendab laiendab.
Õpetaja: Meil on kõik tema. Mina ei tea, Ee, omadused. Ee, mis on niiöelda. Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: meie, aga nüüd on ka mingid meie omadused
Õpetaja: ma Ei, tea, Nina on peas viltu. Vaata, järglastel läheb keeruliseks.
Õpetaja: Minu omadus, on, et nina on Viltu.
Õpetaja: Barentil ei olnud, vaata, aga midagi on teistmoodi. Vaata, saab olla Ka
Õpetaja: see. On see põhiline mõte, et vaba
Õpetaja: ja Aga ongi. Vaata, ei olnud We Dont care about, seda Me ei tahagi seda klassi teha. Kui me hakkaksime klassi tegema, siis me hakkame ise progema. Jälle see tehakse jooksutamise ajal meie ees.
Õpetaja: See klass.
Õpetaja: See see kool. See Selles mõttes, et ega mingit automaagiat ei ole. Ka Kuskil on ikkagi lõpuks ühel või teisel viisil Java kool,
Õpetaja: mis pöördub konkreetse andmebaasi poole. Konkreetse Sql, Iga post Sql iga
Õpetaja: kuskil see on, aga seal tehakse ranta ainet.
Õpetaja: Kui me Pärast vaatame mapper Eid mäperitega. Me saame ka näha, mida. Mida Märtstrack kokku teeb. Sellepärast, et see ei ole rundtimeid. Vaid erinevad ee, genereeritud kood ja kombineeritud Kood
Õpetaja: asja ei olegi. Aga see ongi see, mida me mille üle me oleme täna nagu väga õnnelikud.
Õpetaja: Keegi keegi hea inimene proges selle asja meie eest ära.
Õpetaja: Et me ei pea tegema seda ka asja. Anna ette, ainult mall.
Õpetaja: Kokku lepitud viisil, mis seal on, seal ära progetud. And It will do the rest.
Õpetaja: See kindlasti ei juhtunud üleöö, kui tuli niukene. Asi oli kindlasti. Ee. Päris kõva töö. Ja see Töö kestab. Tänaseni arvates tulevad uued tartuurid, juurde Turvaaugud asjad. Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: The work. Continue its. Not done.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd tulles Kutsha juurde. Lauad Ka
Õpetaja: Kes on teie uus parim sõber.
Õpetaja: Noh, isegi need sõbrad kes on inimesed? Ee, ma olen selles mõttes. Ma olen otsustanud, kui me Kunagi naisega jääme vanaks.
Õpetaja: Me otsustame, et kõik tibud on nagu ära läinud ja tahame oma elu teha kuidagi põnevaks. Me võtame koera,
Õpetaja: ma Panen ta nimeks Jpay.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: kohe kindlasti. Uus parim sõber on nüüd see, et nüüd me hakkame vaatama seda sama asja, et teeme mingi muu näite. Aga teeme selle sama näite.
Õpetaja: Ee, las ta kore isegi olla. Näiteks Ta lubab teha sama, juurde
Õpetaja: kui nüüd, kui te tulete Userrepositorisse Teete kuskile kliki, kuhu iganes Ja siin üleval on väiksed niisugused Shortcut Id, Aga põhimõtteliselt peaks see töölaud nüüd olema nähtav kui ennem ei olnud
Õpetaja: ja teha see Jp padi lahti. Nüüd siin on sisu. Kui ma olen kuskil login Servicesis, pole midagi, teha
Õpetaja: sest et see Ei ole õige asi. Õige koht, kus midagi saaks Putša disainida meile.
Õpetaja: Aga kui oled user depositoris
Õpetaja: siis siin, peaks olema paar varianti nähtaval, Ee, sellest esimesest valikust. See on esimese astme valik.
Õpetaja: Räägime hiljem meetodi peal.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis siin on.
Õpetaja: Find Instance Find Collection Count Exist Delete Mm, kuidas, Võibolla ma ei tea, võibolla.
Õpetaja: Mis Find instants võiks teha? Mis võiks olla see mõte, et aitab meil andmebaasi päringuid teha, mida Võib mida? Mida võiks viidata, Find Instants. Eriti kui me vaatame seda järgmist. Find Collection,
Õpetaja: mis nende kahe vahel võiks olla
Õpetaja: õigel teel Nagu Selles mõttes, Aga kui. Me räägime tabelist? Ee, mis ee mõtted siin võiks olla? Mida seostakse siis Tabeliga
Õpetaja: ei ole, ei ole väli rida
Õpetaja: Video Point instants võiks meile tagastada.
Õpetaja: Mida Find Collection?
Õpetaja: Mitte kõik tingimata, aga potentsiaalselt mitu rida ega mõlemad võivad ka mitte midagi tagastada, kui Sa otsid midagi, mida rida ei leia. Vastata Selleni jõuame siis. Ta ei tagastada. Aga see on potentsia. Siin on üks asi, on kindel
Õpetaja: Vot küsimus on selles. Vaata, kas me nüüd otsime üksikut objekti
Õpetaja: Proovime, Otsime siis kõige mugavamalt Massiivi mõttes listi objektides.
Õpetaja: Kas sinna tuleb midagi? Või Ei, tule. On täiesti eraldi oper. Seda vaatame
Õpetaja: aga mõtteliselt. On Siin juba vahe. Kui me tahaksime uuesti teha seda sama meetodit, mis Kasutajanime parooli ja staatuse järgi otsib meile midagi, mida meie peaksime praegu siit valima.
Õpetaja: Jah, sellepärast, et me tegelikult otsime ühte rida, noh, tegelikult Tehniliselt võttes. Ma võiksin ka niimoodi öelda, et otsi mulle kollektsiooni. On disainitud. Mul on niimoodi et Ta lihtsalt leiab ühe objekti saaks niimoodi ka teha. Vaata aga mul oleks seal kogemises hiljem üksjagu nagu tegemist, nagu. Vaata, et, noh,
Õpetaja: ma pean viitama kõige esimesele objektile, mis, Sest et ma tean, et see esimene objekt tuleb, aga siin on. Selles mõttes Siin on üks Vahe. On see,
Õpetaja: Mis iganes vastus tuleb, siis Ta peab tegema selle objektiks. Mis iganes vastus tuleb Collection I puhul. Ta peab tegema selle listiks. Lihtsalt, mis juhtub siis, kui minu päring Ütleme nii. Mina ütlen, et tee mulle. Üks objekt tagastab mulle üks objekt.
Õpetaja: Kui minu päring tegelikult ee, saab vastuste reast hoopis kaks rida, Siis on juba probleem
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et ta ei saa võtta kahte rida
Õpetaja: või ühte rida neist omavoliliselt teha, sest ühte objekti
Õpetaja: noh sada rida, Aga kuidas me siis seda? Nagu selles mõttes, et me peame ise nagu manageerima. Aga me peame selles mõttes just teadmagi, mida me tegelt siin programmist täna praegult ootame. Kas me tahame mitut Rida leida või või üldse rida? See, et kas üldse midagi, leidis, on eraldi teema, Mida käsitleda. Mis see Count võiks tagastada
Õpetaja: kokku midagi Count, mis ta võiks andmebaasi tabel, kui mina annan mingit sisendparameetrit, otsi mulle, midagi, mida Tagastada
Õpetaja: otsingute arvu tulemust. Noh, normaalse sõna ka siia juurde.
Õpetaja: Mida, mis? Meil on siin tabelid. Meil on veerud ja, noh,
Õpetaja: jah, täpselt. Tahan Näiteks tahaks. Tahaks, nagu tahaks. Nagu võibolla otsida seda, et. Ee. Vaatan, et raamatukogusüsteem. Mitu mitu kasutajat meil on? Praegu? Ee, mitu Raamatut on Meil tagastamata.
Õpetaja: Noh, palun, väga. Kuskil tabelis on mingid staatused sees väljas. Mida iganes. Otsi sealt tabelist kokku. Mind huvitab see number ainult
Õpetaja: kokku, Hetkel on välja laenatud tuhat raamatut Okei, väga tore. Saame teha mingit statistikat ja mis iganes,
Õpetaja: mis seksist võiks teha, mis mis tema mõte võiks olla edasi,
Õpetaja: aga ei tagasta mitte midagi. Noh, no mida ta siis tagastab?
Õpetaja: Aga mitte midagi. Ta ei tagasta. Vot siin ei ole varianti, et kui näiteks selle listi ja selle üksikobjekti puhul, võib öelda, et ta võib tagastada mitte midagi, siis ee, ei tagasta selle see Variant. Kolmandat varianti pole.
Õpetaja: Sa lihtsalt. Sa annad mingid parameetrid.
Õpetaja: Ja mis tema jaoks on? Nagu kui ta leiab kasvõi ühe rea,
Õpetaja: siis tema jaoks on? Noh, on olemas. See ei ütle neile. Vaata, kas on mitu rida.
Õpetaja: Üks rida, tuhat rida, Miljon rida. Ta ütleb seda, et Kas ta midagi leidis? Igal juhul?
Õpetaja: Aga kui te mitte midagi ei leidnud, siis ta ütleb, et las antakse Okei,
Õpetaja: seda seda informatsiooni counkida Meile ei anna objekte ta meile ei anna. Ta Annab meile seda. Kes eksisteerib Self Planeter. Iga ei räägi praktist niikuinii. Nüüd, kui me Tahame otsida konkreetselt. Kasutaja blogib sisse, Siis meid huvitab tema User Idr tema role. Ja me teame juba praegu siis, et
Õpetaja: me tegelikult otsime taga ikkagi ühte objekti.
Õpetaja: Meie muidugi Ülesanne on siis ka muidugi ka nagu garanteerida, et ta mitte kunagi ei leia.
Õpetaja: Ee, rohkem pidu kui üks.
Õpetaja: No kuidas teoreetiliselt saaks leida? Ee, meie kaasuse puhul rohkem pidu kui üks,
Õpetaja: mis peab siis olema meie andmebaasis
Õpetaja: homme korduvad ja kui Me Vaatame kolme parameetreid username. See tähendab seda, et neil peab olema selline kasutaja, sama kasutaja, nimi
Õpetaja: sama parool ja olema ühtlasi ka siis Sama staatusega nagu aktiivne.
Õpetaja: Aga user Id St. Ei ole siin juttu sisendina. Me ei ütle. Me ei Otsi Anna mulle user Id sada Viisteist Seda ei ole ju
Õpetaja: minu. See on siin on küsimus see, et iga rida hekseldatakse läbi selles tabelis ja iga rida saab vastata Ainult Kas True Records? Kas olend
Õpetaja: sellel vastuses või ei ole? Tegime Select laused ja pani, et Select
Õpetaja: kõik vead tulid või tegin veel kümme. Kümme Lihtsalt Nagu mingi. Võrreldes iga rea. Kohta peab otsustama kas jääd, sõelale või mitte onju
Õpetaja: kuidas saab. Jääda siin idee järgi sõelale Programmiliselt tuleb sellele mõelda. Ja süsteemselt tuleb selle mõelda. Süsteemi Arhitektuuris tuleb sellele mõelda. Ma ei saa tekitada sihukest olukorda. Vaata, et minu
Õpetaja: minu Niiöelda mudel ja süsteem ja lähenemine peab garantee. Kui ma teen sellise asja, et ma otsin ainult ühte objekti, siis siin ei tohi olla niukest juhust, et ta saaks leida.
Õpetaja: Ee, kaks sama samasugust.
Õpetaja: Siin süsteemis on see? Kaitstud juba. Kuidas on kaitstud? Käisime ka meil siin tee peal ette kuidagi
Õpetaja: kuidas on tegelikult teada, et seda olukorda ei ole? Võimalik, et see kunagi juhtub, Ei saa realiseeruda,
Õpetaja: Mitte siis ma ei Räägi isegi tõenäosusest. Vaata, et noh, sama prolja kasutaja nimi. Aga pruutsüsteemselt ei ole see võimalik,
Õpetaja: et ta leiab rohkem kui üks miks Mhm Ee, vastuseid, mis tuleb lõpetada,
Õpetaja: ei ole. Siin on midagi muud.
Õpetaja: Kuidas on garanteeritud siin praegu meie süsteemis Nagu seda, et seda olukorda tegelikult Ei saa niikuinii juhtuda.
Õpetaja: Kus kohas,
Õpetaja: mille kohta nii meil oligi? Uniknas, mäletate? Proovisime seal ka. Vaata, et ei saanud lindi nagu kaks korda teha, mis iganes onju? Või et,
Õpetaja: et, ee, meil on user. Name oni määratud. See tähendab seda, et seal andmebaasis niikuinii ei saa mitte kunagi tekkida seda olukorda, et üks kasutaja nimi on rohkem kui ühe korra, Seega programmiliselt. Ma võin julgelt teha sellise konstruktsiooni, et otsi mulle Palun üks rida ja tee sellest objekti.
Õpetaja: Ja mistahes parameetritega. See kunagi ei ole. Teoreetiliselt ka võimalik. Teoreetiliselt puudub ka saaks selle ukse kinni panna, et teoreetiliselt ei ole ka võimalik, et meil see asi juhtub, Aga see on asi, mille peale peab mõtlema,
Õpetaja: et selle peale selles mõttes pead mõtlema, et kui meil seda poleks. Aga näiteks ütleme niimoodi, et süsteem iga kord uue kasutaja Lisa kontrollib, kas selline kasutajanimi on olemas. Mäletate? Location? Iga vaata oli ka, et oli see, et musta. Et sellise sellise nime kasu koht on juba olemas. Põrkasime kokku Vaata Niukene viga,
Õpetaja: et Sise sisene sise. Ütleme niimoodi, et andmete lisamise. Me saame ka programmiliselt kontrollida, et see hetk, kus andmed tekivad.
Õpetaja: Palun, vaata, Kas siin on niuke asi olemas? Ära lisa. Vaata, et nüüd tekib nagu tublid,
Õpetaja: aga see tegelikult ei tähendaks ka veel mitte midagi. Oletame, et me programmiliselt seda haldame. Aga tuleb mingisugune, ee, inimene. Mingi seal, selle ee, meie personali poole pealt, min poole pealt. Keegi, kes lihtsalt Lisab ühe uue kande.
Õpetaja: Aga siis ongi see, et. Noh, aga kui andmebaas ise on ka kaitstud, siis ei saa seal ka midagi teha, Sa ei saa lihtsalt nagu lausega sõita üle. Ee, niiöelda nendest tabelitest Trentidest. Sa ei saa neid kuidagi. Sa ei saa, seal ei ole Mingit Magic Word I. Vaata, et ei. Ma tean, et see. Meil peab olema uniik, aga sellegipoolest lisa
Õpetaja: ta ta ei tööta. Vaata, et Siin on nagu see, sest kõik või mitte midagi. Vaata, on ju, et kas on täpselt vastav tingimustele? Lisame või? Kui ei vasta tingimustele, Siis öeldakse sulle, et ei saa. Noh, siin me juba teame. Vaata, me otsime ühte rida.
Õpetaja: Mhm,
Õpetaja: ma ei ole hea.
Õpetaja: Ei, no läheb katki, kui ta leiab rohkem ridu.
Õpetaja: Aga see see ei tööta. Nii.
Õpetaja: Sa ei tööta nii. Ta ei tööta. Ee, see töötab niimoodi, et Päring läheb päringuna. Ikka. Vaata, et ei saa öelda, et otsi mulle nende sisendparameetrit. Aga kui esimese leiad, siis vaata, et lõpeta töö Ee, Andmebaasis pole nagu niukest. Fratuuri
Õpetaja: andmebaasis on päring. Vaata, mis teeb täpselt seda, mis sa talle ütleb, Anno?
Õpetaja: Jah, Ei, ta ei tagasta ühte
Õpetaja: Ta ei taga. Ma just seda räägingi. Vaata, andmebaas ei tööta niimoodi. Kui mina panen Select from Table User Where user Name Password võrdub See Ja see sisend. Vaata, seal. Ei, Sql. Mootoris ei ole nagu niukest. Nagu sõna või lauset. Vaata, mis ütleks seda, et anna mulle Ainult üks tulemus.
Õpetaja: Tänu esimene tulemus Sellist asja ei ole olemas.
Õpetaja: Ja sellepärast ongi Ma räägin. See asi võib producerida päriselt viga, sellepärast, et on programmeeritud, et sa leiad ainult ühe rea.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole, kui sa leiad kümme rida siis, ta lihtsalt annab kuule. Ei, saa viga ma. Leidsin rohkem
Õpetaja: ee. Tulemusi, kui ühte objekti Mahub kõik. Aga ei ole nagu mingit maagilist sõna. Vaata, mis ütleb, et ah see ei tähenda, et anna mulle esimene.
Õpetaja: See lihtsalt ütleb, et mina nagu pärin andmeid. Tee sellest üks objekt, Kõik
Õpetaja: Jah, seda ma üritangi rääkida. Ta läheb katki.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ütlengi. See ongi nagu siis süsteemi disainimisel tähtis. Vaata, et kui me programmiliselt niiöelda, programmeerime niukseid, asju Vaata, kus ma otsin ühte vastet,
Õpetaja: siis tulebki aru saada ka. Vaata, et tuleb mõista, et kuidas On see terviklikkus garanteeritud? Kas siin on mingi. See asi tihtipeale on, on ju? Kas lihtsalt süsteemselt? Vaata, kõik kes kasutavad meie mingit kasutajaliidest. Kuskil veebilehel lisavad andmeid. Kas seal on mingid kontrollid peal? Kas on andmebaasi peal Mingid kontrollid peal.
Õpetaja: See ta tegelikult alati hallatakse. Ära vaata igas tabelis. Tegelikult tuleb mõelda. Vaata, et kas siin on vaja mingit,
Õpetaja: kui sul on mingisugused andmed. Sul on vaja mõelda andmebaasi. Disainimisel Juba seda Vaatad, Kas on lubad publikaate või mitte? Sul on arhitektuuriline otsus.
Õpetaja: Kas sa lubad või ei luba. Ja kui sa ei luba, siis sa saad ennast kaitsta. Selle. Aasta
Õpetaja: Sa lihtsalt selle tabeli loomise Strip Il või Alteriga. Vahet pole selle Tabelisse endasse. Sa paned Tabeli enda juurde andmebaasisse. Panek on trainid,
Õpetaja: et kitseda, Sa võid seda teha, Sa võid seda teha küll. Mitme veeru,
Õpetaja: et näiteks sul ei ole näiteks. Noh, isikukood on väga lihtne. Näide kus ühest tegelikult piisab, Kasutaja nimi on väga lihtne asi. Kus ühest sellest piisab, on ju? Mis siis, kui näiteks email emailiga? Mingi tabel vaatab, kas ma luban ühte emaili Rohkem kui ühe korra või mitte, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma luban, Äkki siis nagu vaatame mingisuguseid andmeid veel. Lisaks nagu kompotina et viida kolme veeru andmed kokku ja selle põhjal on unitness
Õpetaja: Vähemalt näiteks niimoodi, et vähemalt nende nende Võtame siis näiteks nagu, ee. Isikukoodi meil ei ole, Aga me tahame, et igat isikut saab ühe korra olla. No, mis võiks olla
Õpetaja: sünnikuupäev?
Õpetaja: Noh, kurat, kaks man tamme, kes lihtsalt sünnivad Samal ajal. Ee, ei lugu Aadress, näiteks. Noh,
Õpetaja: nagu Mart Tamm, kes on ee sellise eesnimega sellise perekonnanimega Sellisel kuupäeval, ee kui meil, ei Ole nagu midagi muud. Äkki siis aadress võib olla,
Õpetaja: Kui neid kõike kolme veeru korraga vaadata, siis selline sellise limit, mis saab püsti panna, et ei saa olla meil Mart tamm, kes elab ee tootsi teel. Niiöelda on sündinud samal kuupäeval. No kurat, need on juba kaksikvennad, Siis Juba põhimõtteliselt nagu kes elavad koos. Või
Õpetaja: võibolla mingi. Võibolla mingi kabel nagu mina ei tea. Samal ajal samas kohas. Samas haiglas kukkusime mingi viga juba, vaata. Noh, ütleme niimoodi, et sa saad selle teha nagu
Õpetaja: see konstruktsioon. On võimalik. Kus, nagu siis Teoreetiliselt on võimalik, kuna päriselt Seal ei ole veel endiselt nagu ühtegi. Nagu unikaalset asja nagu isegi kool, on ju.
Õpetaja: Aga. Aga lihtsalt printsiibist saate aru, et niimoodi on võimalik ka unikaalseks määrata üle mitme niiöelda veeru,
Õpetaja: et kui et üle nende kolme veeru, ei saa olla ühtegi publikaat rida, see on võimalus,
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd tuleme tagasi. Me ei jõuagi kuhugi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Enne kui pausile läheme, siis vaatame ära. Vaata, et ei pea neid sõnu siin ise ritta seadma. Ja pealegi meil tegelikult see staaf Ikkagi päris ei meeldi ka
Õpetaja: sama asi siin. See disainer on graafiline kasutajaliides.
Õpetaja: Jah, mida?
Õpetaja: Jah, Oled Ee, user. Depositoris. Tegeleme vahetunnis sellega.
Õpetaja: Ma jah. Ma ei tea. Kus sa otsingusse Paned selle kinni?
Õpetaja: Login ikka.
Õpetaja: Vaata kus oli hea Instruktaaž. Vaata, paned otsingusse. Mul on nagu. Kas on mingi. Ma ei teagi sellest. Nüüd on nagu plugina otsingud Setting otsingud. Siis Settings Ikkagi Jah,
Õpetaja: mitte midagi ei saa aru. Davai,
Õpetaja: Ma ei taha aega veeta sellele. Ma ei
Õpetaja: kohe lähme pausile. Ma näitan ära, kellel iganes mingid Probleemid on.
Õpetaja: Ee, siit. Me valime palun klassiruumi vaikus, muidu ma lihtsalt kaotan enda valitsuse juba varsti. Ma lihtsalt tahan seda ära Jumala eest klikkida, et tuleks aken lahti, nagu
Õpetaja: ma tahan. Nagu rääkida seda, et me ei pea. Neid, ei pea neid meetodeid käsitsi kuidagi kokku panema, Siin ongi see. Kui ma esimest korda nägin seda Kutsha tööriista, siis ma vaatasin, mida pekki. Ee, palju mõnusamalt saab niimoodi toimetada, ja nendel Tõelised võlud tulevad alles Ee, teha seda natukene laiemaks siit natukene
Õpetaja: midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd on niimoodi, et meil on siis teha nüüd nagu seda ee. Meetodit
Õpetaja: kokku panna. See kõik käib läbi user endte. Näed, see on klassiviide Entiti
Õpetaja: Spring Projection or Tto class. Noh, antud juhul Entiti. Ta peab tagastama. See on see küsimus. Kas keegi küsis ka, et kas kohe ei saaks Tto S teha? Andmebaasist saab küll
Õpetaja: Ee, Nii, nüüd on niimoodi, et tema näeb nüüd läbi selle Entity kõiki asju, mis seal, ee, selles konkreetses tabelis, on aga läbi muutuja nimede,
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd ütleme, et minul on mingisugune Condition. Noh, kas klikid siia või paned plussi? Vahet pole, esimene tingimus,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on jutt, et mis Veerust käib jutt. On see atribuut?
Õpetaja: Kui te näete kolmnurgaga asju, siis ma soovitan kohe seal esialgu kokku tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Meil on seal kolm veergu
Õpetaja: Ja ma räägime nüüd entiti mõttes. Meil on Id Role username Password status ja meie tahame otsida läbi, mille
Õpetaja: esialgu kolm tingimust on, aga Me saame ükshaaval neid valida.
Õpetaja: Me tahame otsida, et otsi mulle rida.
Õpetaja: Kus üks sisend on.
Õpetaja: Teed kliki nüüd Condition East niiöelda esku eelistada, tähendaks siis võrdusmärki, kus username võrdub.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: mis teised variandid on? Ta võtab vastavalt tüübile ta Identity Lt näeb, et see user Emel String, Sest need Condition Id, mis ta pakub, on siin ka vastavalt Stringile
Õpetaja: Starts With.
Õpetaja: Mäletate, tegime ka mingisuguse customer. Otsisime Ee roll Name I järgi. Kus esimesed tähed on? C, O, S.
Õpetaja: Teeb siis sellise lause. Vaata, kus ta kasutab sõna. Like select from Table where like role, like
Õpetaja: Ja siis pani. Ee, Cos. Näiteks on sisend. Ja ülejäänud osa on, ee, protsendi Märgiga tulevad niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Not Containes ja kõige klassikalisem on Siis see Iis
Õpetaja: peab olema. Kogu sisu. Username on admin.
Õpetaja: Kui see name on rine, nagu mida iganes, Ignor Case
Õpetaja: saad teha, niimoodi et Mõlemad pooled tegelikult vaikimisi tehakse. Kas siis Lowerkas Iks või Uppercase iks? Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: sisend mis sinna, sisse annad, pannakse Uppercase ja tabelist väärtus mis võetakse, pannakse Uppercase. Kui mõlemad tähed on suured,
Õpetaja: siis ainult määrab rolli see, et kas on sama sõna.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui tahad otsida kuskil Searchist. Vaata mingit telekat või külmkappi või midagi taolist, onju? Ma olen süsteemis, kus ma tahan leida mingisugused tooted. Kas ma panen Tv suurte Tähtedega või Tv väikse tähtedega. Panen T suure tähega väikse tähega. Vahet pole mingi noor,
Õpetaja: kui tahad Ignoorida olu väga lülitad selle sisse.
Õpetaja: Noh, Sisselogimisel vist ei tahaks signoorida.
Õpetaja: Tahaks, et ikka Inimene paneb. Kõik oma kasutaja. Kus ta oli, Jansu? Vaatame siis, Mul on Ee, kas seal On nagu suuri ot. E. S või väike Jt Ees on ikkagi tegelikult kasutaja.
Õpetaja: Täpselt sellisel kujulina. Mis kuradi kasu on? Vaata, ütleb, ka, et kasuta siin nimes niiöelda suuri tähti väikseid tähti. Ja jumala eest, hüüumärki ka. Veel. Vaata või midagi taolist, on ju? Teate ikka seda? Noh, see ongi see mõte. Vaata, et ongi sensitive. Kindlasti ei taha.
Õpetaja: Ma ei räägi. See on alles esimene tingimus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tahaks veel vaadata.
Õpetaja: Näete, nüüd on operaator on and we
Õpetaja: No änd, onju. Kõik. Kui kõik pooled on ee tõesed, siis meie jaoks on tõene järelikult rida Jääb sõelale atribuut, mille järgmisena tahaks vaadata, Võiks olla
Õpetaja: Password ning. Ja. Sõidan kõik veel midagi veel.
Õpetaja: Tootlus oli, ka on ju? Noh, paneme otse jälle ise otsustada. Vaata, on ju password.
Õpetaja: Kui meil oleks siin Praegult, on kõik String Id.
Õpetaja: Kui meil oleks see mingi numbriline väärtus
Õpetaja: Kui meil oleks mingi kuupäev või mis iganes, siis need Condition Id on siin teistsugused, mis ta pakub? Noh, näiteks numbrilistel väärtustel, on see, Et kas on suurem või väiksem. Kas jääb kuskile vahele? Saate mõttes aru,
Õpetaja: et neid variante on? On ju No, mingi poole on väärtus head head ja
Õpetaja: ma praegu korra näitan. Wrap Type on ka wrapp. Type on, mida saaks kasutada, aga me seda praegult veel ei tee, Lihtsalt see on see, et mähi user objekt
Õpetaja: sisse. Me vaatame seda ka. See on väga hea tööriist.
Õpetaja: Kui me otsime, otsime niiöelda ühte Ee, objekti
Õpetaja: siis järjestus. Meile huvi ei paku,
Õpetaja: Aga siit Advanced I alt. Tuleb Veel asju juurde.
Õpetaja: On kõik see tehtud väga suureks niiöelda, et oleks teil parem näha.
Õpetaja: Aga endal on natuke raske. Näete,
Õpetaja: siin on veel mingisuguseid näiteid. Üks asi, mis meid siin huvitab.
Õpetaja: Mm, vanasti Oli nagu see option ka huvitav peidetada.
Õpetaja: Davai. Vaatame, kuidas ta teeb, aga ma ei näe ühte.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, Näe ühte optionit, mida Ma vaikimis oleks näinud. No ütleme okei. Või näete ta ise meetodi nime. Kas kuskil on võimalik defineerida?
Õpetaja: Ei ole, et ta ise paneb Selle kokku vajut on okei.
Õpetaja: Ta nüüd tegi konstruktsiooni. Mõlemad konstruktsioonid. Find user, Pie Find Pie
Õpetaja: Fine Pie on kõige lühem viis Mis repositoris Me oleme
Õpetaja: userrepositoris või mida ta tegelikult siis potentsiaalselt üldse findida saab? Ainult user Id.
Õpetaja: Mingid muud objektid ei saa. Vaata, et et see Siin on nagu ekstra sõna, mis tegelikult
Õpetaja: on vajalik või ei ole vajalik, Vaata aga nüüd kui ma panin selle, siis ta on tegelikult Samasugune on nii? Järjekord on vist nüüd erinev. Onju
Õpetaja: ei ole, kõik on, aga see on. Mul on kohe kaks korda läinud, on ju
Õpetaja: Kogemata on läinud kaks korda. Ee, ma konstrueerisin selle valesti.
Õpetaja: Noh, võtan lahti. Võtan Find instansi. Ma võin kiirelt teha. Ärge teie tehke, onju Võibolla saite. Ee, toidsin usernane
Õpetaja: otsinud vastik. Ta teeb nüüd Iga kord Jätab Nüüd siis kitsaks vä? See hakkabki nüüd elu olema. Vä, Idiootne
Õpetaja: Tupid, Ee, password ja.
Õpetaja: Ja vähemalt teist korda päästtaatus.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on lihtsalt, et see on niukene, et sa saad. Minule meeldib Selline variant mulle meeldib niimoodi, et otsi mida?
Õpetaja: Sellepärast see meediat kõneleb. Muidu sa pead vaatama nagu seda asja nagu tervikuna user repositori find, Noh, user I guess by username. Rohkem. Mina paneks sada protsenti selle siia.
Õpetaja: Tegi meile samasuguse asja sisuliselt Noh, hästi. Väikse erinevusega, mis on, Niuke.
Õpetaja: Väga tore.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis see töötab. Seda saab proovida ka. Me ju proovisime seda. Jah, töötas.
Õpetaja: Teame nüüd selle pausi, kellel on. Oota Korra ma vaatan midagi. Kas loogiline, et sul või midagi läks kaduma? I love optimizing. Võtame need tühjad read ära. Ma teen siin praegu ära, kuigi. Noh, koodi tasandil. Midagi siin tegelikult ju väga juurde ei tulnudki.
Õpetaja: Tuli ainult tühjad Read Tegelt võib Rolback Ida. Me ei teinud ju mitte midagi siin idee järgi.
Õpetaja: Isegi see üks meetod, mis me tegime juurde, Seda võite ka ära kustutada. Teeme kohe uuesti
Õpetaja: Davai. Teeme siis selle pausi ära
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen pausile ka.
Õpetaja: Et, ee. Tegime siis siia peale sammuga tagasi, et ee. Tegime niimoodi, et selle meetodi nimest me ekstraktime. Ee, kollase Pirniga
Õpetaja: ekstrakti. Me, ee. Niiöelda siia meetodi ülesse annotatsioonid,
Õpetaja: mis tegelikult teeb nüüd. Seda sama asja. Vaata, mis ta ütleb. Select From user, kus Useri user name
Õpetaja: on mingisugune väärtus.
Õpetaja: Kus Password on? Mingisugune väärtus
Õpetaja: ja staatus on mingisugune väärtus. Kuidas konkreetselt see asi hetkel töötab, on niimoodi, Et mis iganes siin on, kokku kolm sisendit, on ju nii? Üks,
Õpetaja: kaks ja kolm.
Õpetaja: Kuidas See asi töötab oma positsioonide järgi. Et sisuliselt Võib öelda,
Õpetaja: et see siin on positsioonil. Üks positsioonil. Kaks positsioonil, kolm.
Õpetaja: Kui ta teeb Sql lause, siis ta kasutab selle jaoks seda informatsiooni siin, et Us tabelist on vaja võtta.
Õpetaja: Kus username on? Selle väärtusega, Mis on siin muutujad? Aga kus Password on?
Õpetaja: See, mis on siin, Kui meie teame, et. Ee, meil need sisendid on.
Õpetaja: Näiteks admin,
Õpetaja: üks, kaks, kolm, ja. Aa,
Õpetaja: siis. Kuidas taustal toimub, on see, et kui see lektlause tehakse. Siis sinna läheb, Siis sisend
Õpetaja: admin siia. Tegelikult tuleb sellest sildist.
Õpetaja: Kuus, kaks, kolm, stringina ja.
Õpetaja: Aa, kas see on teile Arusaadav,
Õpetaja: et siin üleval on siis lause, millest tegelikult lõpuks tuleb ka päris post lause.
Õpetaja: Select from Table, bla bla blabla, täpselt nii, nagu Me ennem proovisime neid Selectlauseid ja need väärtused saadakse
Õpetaja: nendest muutujatest positsioonide järgi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. See on üks variant.
Õpetaja: Kui me selle praegu ekstraktisime, siis Ma tegin meelega esialgu niimoodi,
Õpetaja: sest ta tihtipeale vaikimisi ta niimoodi tuleb.
Õpetaja: Aga meile meeldib teine variant.
Õpetaja: Ma võtaks Control Setiga või kustutab lihtsalt selle siit ära teha. Seda uuesti.
Õpetaja: Aga seekord valida, et ee ekstrakti. Selline annutatsioon siia ülesse. Query. Annutatsioon aga. Ühtlasi me soovime
Õpetaja: vaatame. Mis, Ta siin pakub short name.
Õpetaja: Ta pakub meile võimalust juba siin meetode nimi ümber ära muuta. Okei, seda korra praegult ei tee. Vahet pole, saaks seda teha, Aga see mõte on küll. Sellel see just see mõte on see,
Õpetaja: et nüüd on meil adoptatsioon üleval, mis juhib meie Niiöelda süsteemi. Ee, lause peab tulema, aga siin on. Ka. Kasuta nimelisi parameetreid. Ennem olid meil just positsioonidega parameetreid. Üks kaks ja kolm seal Selles Squeri sees.
Õpetaja: Kui me paneme neid parameetre, aitame. Okeid.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta muutis seda natukene.
Õpetaja: Enam ei ole siin positsioon üks, vaid hoopis viidatakse
Õpetaja: nimele username. Kui ma ütlen. Control B,
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kui ta kukub sisse üldse. Kas ta oskab kuhugi minna?
Õpetaja: Ee siis tema nüüd viitab tegelikult sellele sildile,
Õpetaja: mille ees on ära öeldud, et
Õpetaja: siin üleval. Me kasutame niukest nime nagu username
Õpetaja: ja me mõtleme et selle, sisend, See mõte on endiselt sama.
Õpetaja: Ehk siit sellest usernameist.
Õpetaja: Noh, ütleme siin keskelt. Tuleb kokku.
Õpetaja: Admin siia. Password I tuleb
Õpetaja: üks, kaks, kolm, Olen Namlock maas.
Õpetaja: Üks, kaks, kolm ja staatuseks tuleb.
Õpetaja: Aa, ehk Nüüd seotakse need samad muutujad, mis on siin
Õpetaja: esialgu ükshaaval nende nimedega, mis tulevad Nendest
Õpetaja: ja need väärtused lõpuks tulevad siia. Siia tuleb admin.
Õpetaja: Siia tuleb üks, kaks, kolm ja siia tuleb aa, juhul kui
Õpetaja: tee nimi ja See nimi omavahel nagu kattuvad. Et Ei, ole erinevust. Näiteks kui siin oleks. Vaata, ee, see. Ma tahaks muutuja nimeks panna, Näiteks
Õpetaja: ma ei tea. Login user name.
Õpetaja: Näiteks kui ma tahaksin teha niimoodi,
Õpetaja: login username. Aga siin selles tag I sees,
Õpetaja: Sooviksin siis kasutada seda sellelt sisendit. Siis praegult Selline Parameeter on hädavajalik, Sest kuidas muidu tema teaks,
Õpetaja: et millega See on imeline parameeter, aga juhul, kui meil on see nimi Täpselt sama,
Õpetaja: mis see nimi. Ja täpsemalt Tegelikult see nimi. Kui need nimed omavahel kattuvad, siis Need on kainda nagu abirattad, mida üldse ei olegi vaja.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast. Oota, kustusin ära. See on niikuinii. Me teeme seda kolmandat korda. Veel
Õpetaja: Ee, et seda ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast nad kattuvad Niikuinii need siin kattuvad omavahel.
Õpetaja: Seda abiratast ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Ainult Siin oleks teoreetiliselt vaja, kui ma tahaksin kasutada Siin login username aga siin query Sees tahaks kasutada username
Õpetaja: siis. Oleks vaja seda abiratast aga. Loomulikult on meie mõtle. Mõistlik. On Teha niimoodi et selle, asja nimi ongi usernane. Noh, miks peaks kuidagi erinevalt nimetama? Aga see võimalus on olemas,
Õpetaja: Sest et siis me saame koristada ära. Need abistavad annutatsioonid
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et Jp võtab vaikimisi ise. Eelduseks, et sa kasutad sama nimesi siin. Vaadake, süntaks on siin hästi. Tähtis. Kool on.
Õpetaja: Noh, et kuidas ta saab aru. Mälet tuleb tuttav. Natuke näiteks nagu sellest. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Frontist. Vaata, ei, me mõtleme muutujat mitte teksti. Näiteks
Õpetaja: kain Samamoodi võiks mõelda, on Ju Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd me kustutaksime selle kogu selle asja aa ära.
Õpetaja: Uue stepp.
Õpetaja: Ja meil ei olegi plaanis kunagi teha niimoodi, et, ee, me Kõigepealt teeme nimelise meetodi ja siis hakkame mingi ekstraktima ja. Ja niimoodi jõudma lõpptulemuseni. Mis eesmärk oli? Ma panen ikka korra tagasi. Vaadake, see Asi töötab niimoodi
Õpetaja: Kui Quer I Annotatsioon on meetodi peal siis lause. Pannakse puhtalt selle annotatsiooni järgi et andmebaasi ee. Läheb
Õpetaja: noorekest kuskilt nagu, Pole vaja, võtame siit Parem see. Ee, Kus oli see
Õpetaja: Pdf? Aga tegin restardi kiirelt. Panen, kui te võtate selle, Ma teen ikkagi lahti,
Õpetaja: Ee, materjali buildid. Ei, valid. Ee, üldine võistlus, kui normaalsesse kohta panna. Iga kord ma otsin teda. Veisi
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme alati.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Käib sellest Teisest käest, loomulikult.
Õpetaja: Jutt käib sellest.
Õpetaja: Päeva lõpuks peab siia andmebaasi suunas saab minna. Tavaline lausa.
Õpetaja: Küsimus ongi lihtsalt selles, et kuidas ta selle lause kokku paneb. Kui on selline koeri annutatsioon, siis
Õpetaja: ta paneb selle lause selle informatsiooni põhjal kokku.
Õpetaja: Kui seda pole,
Õpetaja: siis peab olema selline Meetodi nimi, mis on õige struktuuri ja süsteemiga, et ta oskab selle nime järgi.
Õpetaja: Ta paneb kas nime või siis selle adatotsiooni järgi, aga Mitte nagu mõlema järgi.
Õpetaja: See on nagu välistav olukord. Kui annutatsioon on olemas, siis ta meetodi nime ei vaata ja seda annutatsiooni pole. No Siis tal ei ole mingit muud varianti Kui vaadata. Selle nime järgi,
Õpetaja: mis paindlikkuse meie saame, on see, et nüüd me saame selle asja siin ära refaktureerida või tahaks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ongi see. Võimalus. Ärge tehke teda praegu kaasa. Mõtete et siin ma saaksingi nüüd öelda näiteks, et Point User by.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see informatsioon enam ei ole. Alles
Õpetaja: Et nime, järgi saaks panna kokku lause jällegi.
Õpetaja: Päeva Lõpuks
Õpetaja: päeva lõpuks peab minema Päring andmebaasi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta selle kokku paneb? Selle sama laadse Ee, kirjaviisi pealt. See ei ole siin. Ei ole see Electrom table. Näete kuskil Sõna table ei ole.
Õpetaja: On ka olemas niuke ajane asi. Nagu
Õpetaja: saab siia sisse vist teha seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, korra kommenteerin välja.
Õpetaja: Ei tea, muidugi Ei, peaasi. Kas äkki tuleb siis peale seda järgi?
Õpetaja: Ee, on võimalik teha niimoodi ka, et ma koeris. Ütlen nagu päris Select Rombable,
Õpetaja: ehk Siis see on siis sõna otseses mõttes. Ee, päris päring, mis läheb andmebaasi suunas
Õpetaja: Aga seda siis juba. Ee, seda siis juba Ee, stiilis
Õpetaja: seda ei soovita kasutada. Kunagi Native Quer It
Õpetaja: Ee Vanasti oli näiteks lhv S Oli mure see. Et, nagu ütleme niimoodi et, keegi kunagi Väga vist ei viitsinud süveneda. Vaata, et selle asja kokkupanemine, et Jpa stiilis niiöelda. Quer. I Kokkupanemine alguses. Oli kuidagi keeruline ja arusaamatu nagu Kuidas seda tuleb? Teha? Tegelikult ei olnud see mitte midagi keerulist.
Õpetaja: Siis kui sa päris oli olemas. Mis sul endal andmebaasis töötas, oli lihtsalt Ja Native Queriga
Õpetaja: No. Selle, probleem on see et, native query on Andmebaasi spetsiifiline
Õpetaja: kui meie. Täna. Oleme ms sql Ja Homme tahame olla Siis kõik native päringud. Mis on siin selles tavalises tekstis päringuna, siis nad selle kirja viis, et dialekt võib olla natukene vale,
Õpetaja: kui me Vahetame enda teenusepakkujat ja vahetame nagu seda andmebaasi mootorit. Me peaksime kõik Script Id üle käima ja tegema korda
Õpetaja: seda native It väga ei tahaks kasutada. Ütleme niimoodi, sest see asi ei ole ühegi konkreetse.
Õpetaja: See on, kui me viitame selle klassidele userd.
Õpetaja: Noh, mingil muutujatele mis on, Vaata, et, ee, et see on spetsiifiline query Ja. Niimoodi tahakski neid teha
Õpetaja: nüüd. Kuidas, seda asja teha on see et, kui, me alustame Nüüd puhtalt lehelt. Nullist ei ole. Optimizing. Näiteks,
Õpetaja: kui ma nüüd tulen siia ja võtan jälle selle disaineri lahti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd See Esimese astme valik on see, et kas tee mulle selline lahendus, kus meetodi nime järgi
Õpetaja: paneme koeri kokku või lisame talle peale koeri anotatsiooni,
Õpetaja: Siis minu soovitus On see, et loomulikult alati koeri. Miks me saame seda nime lühendada?
Õpetaja: Igal juhul tahaks seda, nagu kui vähegi võimalik. Pluss, vaadake, see asi annabki mingit paindlikkust. Näiteks meetode nime järgi. Update pole võimalik. Teha
Õpetaja: Akweeri Järgi on võimalik. Jah.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui tulla siia quer. I Peale
Õpetaja: valid Koeri siit võivad valida, et mida Sa tahad. Otsin ühte rida. Võtad pomm.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd saad siit uuesti panna, et soovin, et atribuut Oi, Hakkabki nii olema. Kas teil on ka nii vä?
Õpetaja: Issand, kui idiootne Ee, et tahan otsida usernimi järgi Tahan otsida Password I järgi.
Õpetaja: Tahan otsida.
Õpetaja: Staatuse järgi on nii
Õpetaja: nii. Ja nüüd, kui me valitseme selle quer I Variandi siis, siia advanced I Alla tuli üks uus valik
Õpetaja: Name parameeter.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd see, et kas me tahame näha seal neid positsioone.
Õpetaja: Ee küsimärk. Üks ko, küsimärk, Kaks ja küsimärk. Kolm või Me tahame, et on imeline.
Õpetaja: Seda peab ainult ühe korra valima, et edaspidi jätab selle meelde. Muidugi tahame nimedes. Seda on palju lihtsam koodis lugeda.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin niiöelda. Tulemuste järjestus.
Õpetaja: See muutub relevantseks siis, kui meil on mingisuguse kollektsiooni päring.
Õpetaja: Hetkel tagastatakse lihtsalt puserit. Mingit järjestust ei saa, olla Pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Wrapp Type ist. Kohe räägime ka, kui Vajutame nüüd. Okei,
Õpetaja: siis näeme, et ta tegi jälle niukse meetodi
Õpetaja: aga mis ta Tegi nüüd kohe. Ta lisas kohe selle koeri.
Õpetaja: Ja mis me saame siit ära kaotada, on need abirattad? Meil Ei, olegi plaanis et need, oleks erineva nimega
Õpetaja: siin peab muidugi meeles hoidma, et juhul kui sul, see nimi on, mis ei meeldi ja ma ütlen, et tulevad hetked, Kus meile ei meeldi. Näiteks on lihtsalt mingi sisend. On Id.
Õpetaja: Mis? Id City? Id Location Id. Siis me tahame nagu ära määrata vaata, Et Aa, et see on. Ei, ära ei taha kasutada nime Id. Siis, kui sa teed muudatuse siin, sa pead tegema alati ka muudatuse, quer. Is muidu. Asi ei tööta rundtime il.
Õpetaja: Aga, need abirattad saadame. Pensionile noh. Ja, nüüd oleks niimoodi et, me saame selle meetodi nimega teha Mida iganes
Õpetaja: Minule meeldib selline konventsioon, et find
Õpetaja: subjekt. Mis? Sest Et ta ei saagi midagi muud leida. Aga ikkagi. Kas ma otsin Ee, need meetodide nimi. Kas ma otsin userit või userreid? Mitmes näitab siis juba? See on informatsioon
Õpetaja: Finduser.
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma ei taha midagi, enam seda pakub.
Õpetaja: Mine ära.
Õpetaja: Ütleksin selle paiga, Ootame ära. Miks?
Õpetaja: Sest et tegelikult juba muutub iseenesest selgeks, Kui me vaatame ka muutuja nimes
Õpetaja: tava uuesti. Võibolla mul oli ka korraks jäänud, aga.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: no midagi. On. Aga ärme siia toppama Ja nüüd tuli
Õpetaja: nüüd ma juhin tähelepanu, et Ee, siin on niikuinii. Igas. Kohas on pidevalt nuppe. Mitu korda. Kui ma. Olen mingi haru peal, mul on siin push. Ma saan minna Õpetaja Feb ee lokali pealt ja siit vajutada. Push Nuppe on igal pool. Ee, pange tähele neid asju Siin
Õpetaja: Adspring repositor i Rive method, Koerimeetod, Et siit samast vajutades saad juba kiiremini valida ka neid samu valikaid,
Õpetaja: et lihtsam olekski mitte tulla siit vaid siit
Õpetaja: kui üldse need on genereeritavad meetodid Mäletate, Me genereerisime näiteks ja konstruktoreid.
Õpetaja: Ee, genereerimismenüü, mis muidu saaks parema klõpsuga. Tee lahti, inspekt ja
Õpetaja: Ee saab avada alt Insert. Kui käpat tahaks üldse hoida. Selle Peal vajutakse alt insert.
Õpetaja: Mm, vanasti pakkus siit ka kahju. Miks siis me ei saa vanasti Aa Repositoori method. Muidugi.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga nüüd on niimoodi. Kõigepealt oled need meetodi variandidest. Oled Quer I Variandid aga, Põhimõtteliselt jõuab siit ka
Õpetaja: ta teeb, selle akna lõpuks lahti. Mõtest saate aru.
Õpetaja: Nüüd üks asi, Ee. On siin veel, mis? Tegelikult, ee, vajab selles mõttes timmimist,
Õpetaja: mida Find instance leiab
Õpetaja: ühe rea.
Õpetaja: Aga kui mul on mingisugused parameetrid, mis ei sobi, kui ma kasutajani. Ma ei hittigi. Vaata seda kasutajat,
Õpetaja: mis ta siis tagastab, kui ta midagi ei leia.
Õpetaja: Null I Sellepärast user, on ju Objekt. On ju ainukene vari variant. Kuidas teda saab Mitte olla, on Null, onju?
Õpetaja: Mm Okei, et meil on ikkagi alati Selline Sisendandmed tulevad kuskilt. Ee, sealt internetist. Ütleme siis nii
Õpetaja: parameetreid, et kuidas siin ei Ole ju mingit garantiid, et kas leiab või Ei, leia. Mitte nüüd,
Õpetaja: kui mina ütlen korra uuesti lahti, Me ei hakka siin midagi muutma, Aga kui ma valisin siin üleval Niukene asi Et mähiobjekt.
Õpetaja: Mähi Usero objekt millegi sisse. No ma näitan võibolla midagi, mis tundub alguses nagu Loogilisem on see, et kui ma ütlen, et otsime kollektsiooni
Õpetaja: Noh, ma panen mingi suvalise quer I Siia
Õpetaja: ma. Ei tea otsime kõiki kasutajaid Staatuse järgi näiteks. Ma ei tea kõiki activ kasutajaid,
Õpetaja: mida praegult. See meetod tagastab objekti mõttes listi, Millest
Õpetaja: see on nüüd see? Asja? Selle Asja nimi on Wrapping. Et sa mähid ühe objekti ümber teise objekti, kui mõelda sellele sõnale. Wrapping. See on nagu tehniline termin.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul Oli üks kolleeg, kes kogu aeg muidugi kasutas sõna mähkima hoopis ee seda, et mida sa nagu jamad. Nagu Vaata,
Õpetaja: üks kolleeg argo oli kogu aeg. Vaata, et mida sa mähid või ära mähi. Vaata, On ju, et siis me ära jama vaata. See ei ole mõeldud seda Siin on mõeldud seda, et listi sees on user. Objektiiv. Nüüd saab olla Mitu
Õpetaja: Nii süntaksist annab niimoodi välja, list millest puserobjektidest kast massiiv Jada user objektidest.
Õpetaja: Ma korra võtan selle tagasi. Ma natukene tormasin, et kui mina panen Find Collections siis vaadake on üleval juba ära määrata
Õpetaja: List jaava util on ju, et sina rapid selle Need objekti selle objekti sisse. See on Niukene list. Objekt. Sinna saab mitmeid neid käia, Aga idee järgi. Vaata, üks objekt. List objekti sees on user. Objektiid? Noh, võib mitmuses mõelda. Võib ka üks olla, võib ka mitte midagi olla, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga meil on siin mingisugune asi, mida pakutakse, et kui otsid ühte rida, siis ta listi loomulikult. Ei paku, sest Lisa nad märku. Ma otsin userit, on ju? Aga ta pakub midagi. Optional. Seda ma isegi ei tea, mis on. Mind isegi ei huvita ee, Aga Optional
Õpetaja: Opsional tuli alates. Ee, jaava kaheksast
Õpetaja: küsimus. Mis asi? See, mis asi see järsku on? Ma mäletan, kui ma esimest korda nägin Midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Optsionaal,
Õpetaja: Nurgaliselt solvud, user. Kui ma esimest korda nägin mingit niukest jama, siis mõtlesin, mis kuradi. Ja ma nägin selle kuskil Production koodis.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlesin, mis asi see veel on?
Õpetaja: Tegelikult enamvähem. Nagu Lõpuks siis sain aru mis asi see on, aga ma kunagi endale nagu päris selgeks ei teinud. Vaata, et nagu Miks ta hea on, kuidas ta toimib ja mis võimalused kõik siin nagu on?
Õpetaja: See on nagu See on nagu parim asi andmebaasiga toimetades.
Õpetaja: Mis tähendab option on sibulat valikuline.
Õpetaja: Vaata, siin ongi nagu see variant, et see ee, täpselt sellist Olukorda üritabki nagu,
Õpetaja: ee. Manageerida, et kas on või ei ole ta ei pea olema.
Õpetaja: Mis peab olema. Peab olema kuskil objekt.
Õpetaja: No see Teid ei kõ kõneta kuidagi. Ee, siis selle jaoks olen ma teinud. Loomulikult ühed pildikesed
Õpetaja: neile Ju meeldivad pildikesed, eksole?
Õpetaja: Ah, Comiti vä Okei, Davai.
Õpetaja: Teeme komitee.
Õpetaja: Nii, no tuleb mingi hetk. Nii kui nüüd pildiseeria, tuleb nüüd vähe pikem opsional. Pildiseeria.
Õpetaja: See on niuke kast ja opsenalist. Te peaksitegi mõtlema nagu kui kastist.
Õpetaja: See kast on väga eriline. Ta on Niukene Ult.
Õpetaja: Kus on seal kolm tegevust, et Ee Geth, anna Viis present on olemas ja on, et on tühi
Õpetaja: See kast on selline naiskast. Vaata, kus idee järgi on. Siis need lambid
Õpetaja: seal on Lambid, truu ja foos.
Õpetaja: Kui puldid katsuda East present meetodit,
Õpetaja: siis mis te arvate, kumb lombike peaks põlema minema? Eeldusel et seal on midagi sees.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ei ole sees pool,
Õpetaja: pange tähele selle meetodi. Mõte, et tegelikult on olukorda eelkõige, nagu võiks mõelda, et see on nagu Primary value,
Õpetaja: siis on meil. Kui praegu seal midagi on, see. Siis Ta näitab, et
Õpetaja: kui seal ei ole, midagi sees, näitab, Force on See Selge
Õpetaja: see nüüd on. Selles mõttes töötab nüüd vastupidiselt,
Õpetaja: et olukord. Kui see ei ole midagi sees, siis ta läheb põlema,
Õpetaja: Aga kui ta teise Mti. Aga kui seal on midagi sees, siis ta ütleb.
Õpetaja: Okei, okei, Meetod get kasti lahti.
Õpetaja: Ta võtab sealt väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Nad võtad objekti. Anna mulle sealt. Sellest kastiks on küsimusi. Kurat, jätke mitte.
Õpetaja: Okei, Kass on kadunud?
Õpetaja: Ei tea, kas lapsed on ta jälle kasti kinni pannud.
Õpetaja: Ma olen Nice Family elust enesest mina, mu õde kunagi. Ee, kolisime suvila tänavale pääskülas. Suur maja, Suur aed.
Õpetaja: Kass Nimega Pinta Musta värvi. Hästi, ilus. Kass oli?
Õpetaja: Ee, suur. Seal Ühes kohas olid jänesepuurid, mis ei olnud kunagi kasutuses. Aga mingid jänesepuurid olid
Õpetaja: Üks kord õega Mängisime, et kass on jänes.
Õpetaja: Kas see oli kolm päeva kallal, et Ee,
Õpetaja: vanemad küsisid, mis toimub, on? Kas siis teate midagi? Ei Jaa, Jah,
Õpetaja: kass on kadunud. Ei tea, kas lapsed on ta jälle kasti kinni pannud.
Õpetaja: Kui jah, see on see olukord. Vaata, kui jah,
Õpetaja: siis Pean ta koheselt vabastama. Ei, ei huvita meid siin kontekstis Ainult see,
Õpetaja: kui. Jah, see on mingi tegevus.
Õpetaja: Noh, see ongi see kast, kuhu Lapsed, varemgi on seda kassi pannud.
Õpetaja: Mis nuppu tasuks praegu panna? Meil, mis meid huvitab?
Õpetaja: Mis present? Aa näitab, et et seal vist ongi asja.
Õpetaja: Kas sa siin Nüüd me nüüd me Vaatame. Nüüd, me saame teada, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas? Me ta kätte saame.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: noh, kellegi telefon Väike vestlus.
Õpetaja: Teeme täna kartulisalatit.
Õpetaja: Kas on vaja kartulit osta?
Õpetaja: Pea vaatama. Kas kartul on otsas?
Õpetaja: Meil on siis kartul.
Õpetaja: Kui jah, siis on vaja poest kartulit. Osta Make sense,
Õpetaja: mis meid huvitab. Meid huvitab ainult see olukord.
Õpetaja: Kui kartulit pole Enam on ju kartul on otsas, sul On vaja midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Mis nuppu võiks vajutada?
Õpetaja: Noh, pole isegi seda kasti vaja. Avada On ju, et pole nimi meil siin sees,
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: Opsal on klass ja ala sees
Õpetaja: on klassiha sees. Seal on olemas meet Need samad meetodid ja teisi meetodeid veel
Õpetaja: täna. Kui ma teeksin neid õppematerjale, siis ma isegi Ee, Highlight iksin hoopis midagi paremat. Isegi tähendab, need on vaja. Need on kontseptsioonina niikuinii vajalik, arusaades, et need taustal toimetavad. Ja kogu see kontseptsioon. Näeme Is present.
Õpetaja: Klass on lahti tehtud. Structure tööriist. Või Tab on seal lahti tehtud. Näitab kõiki meetodeid pole seda varemgi vaadanud. Vaata, näita kõike. Meetodid. Mis seal klassis on?
Õpetaja: Siin on siis need meetodid olemas? Kett kett tagastab mingisugust objekti vastavalt Siis mis iganes seal, kass peab olema East Present ja E Sent I tagastavad poole
Õpetaja: Jälle sisse logimine.
Õpetaja: Meil on kaks Case.
Õpetaja: Ühel korral Üritab keegi kasutada sisse Ee, logida. Rain. Üks, kaks, kolm,
Õpetaja: Keegi teisel koeral üritab või samal ajal Brauserist. Vahet pole, see on meie tabel Select Prom User.
Õpetaja: Raine on olemas.
Õpetaja: Student. Id ei ole olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil siin ee variandid, et ee, seda sama niiöelda meetodit. Ee saab siis teha niimoodi, et me ütleme, et annaks meile ka suseri.
Õpetaja: Või me saame niimoodi Wrapp ida selle tulemuse sisse. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ehk siis Üks tagastab userit, teine tagastab kaste,
Õpetaja: aga kasti sees saab käia. Ainult user. Objekt. Just vaatasime ka Seda Vaata, süntakse mõttes. See Paneb. Välja, Niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: nüüd See on juba see jälle. Jpase on juba siin. Ära niiöelda ee tehtud, et kirjuta ainult sellises kirjaviisis ja ta teeb selle objekti ja paneb ise kaste ridagi. Koodi ei pea kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Vaatame seda esimest varianti. Ee, rain üks, kaks, kolm üritab sisse logida.
Õpetaja: Ta leiab Ee. Tulemuse. Andmebaasist luuakse objekt.
Õpetaja: Suser Id on kaks ja user. Nameline, Üks, kaks, kolm. Segas leidmise objekti.
Õpetaja: Kui stuudent üks, kaks, kolm, läheb sinna sisse. Sellist asja pole. No mis siis, user siis on? Sellisel juhul,
Õpetaja: kui ta. Kui teame, et ta, ei leia studentid, pole Üks kasutamine polnud seal valikutes.
Õpetaja: Mis Siis saab olema useri väärtus?
Õpetaja: Tulemused on halb,
Õpetaja: kui me sellise konstruktsiooniga näete. Siin on Find user By User Name Password. Kui meil on selline olukord, kus me kasutame siis seda otse objekti.
Õpetaja: Siis, kui me nüüd tahame kontrollida, et kas me midagi leidsime või mitte, siis me peame tegema niukse lause lause, et kui user on all,
Õpetaja: siis viska iga vale kasutajani või parool, kood, Üks, üks, Mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Kui Rainiga nii, tuleb, siis on. Objekt vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Kas Sellisel juhul minnakse If lause sisse või mitte ei minda
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et on ju midagi sees. Järelikult viga ei visata.
Õpetaja: Vale kasutajamine ei tulnud Rin sai sisse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd üritab sama asja student.
Õpetaja: Noh, studenti Tabelis pole järelikult user on.
Õpetaja: On all seega see If lausa. Kas nad on all?
Õpetaja: Järelikult visatakse Exception poole kasutamine või bürool vale kasutajanimi Bürool.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et ee. Siin oli selline olukord.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vaatame seda sama asja. Aga mis siis kui oleks meil, niimoodi et see Find user ei tagastab meile userit, vaid tagastab hoopis Optional kasti
Õpetaja: samamoodi. Teeme kõigepealt Rainiga selle asja läbi,
Õpetaja: siis, mis me saame tulemuse me nüüd ei saanud seda user objekti,
Õpetaja: Vaid mida me saame. Me saame Optional objekti.
Õpetaja: Kus sees siis on? User, Objekt kast
Õpetaja: kass, millel sees on kass, Või Ei ole kass. No siin on kasutaja. Rain on siin kasti sees. Kurat,
Õpetaja: väga kurb.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb studentiga, siis kasti sees on nal, Aga kast on?
Õpetaja: Mõlemal juhul tagastatakse kast.
Õpetaja: Objekt on.
Õpetaja: See on põhiline. Kas ta on midagi? Ei ole tagastab. Igal juhul,
Õpetaja: kui me vaatame nüüd seda Optionali kasutust. Ee, nüüd uuesti. Kus meil enam ei ole user.
Õpetaja: Kui meil on siin Rain, siis. Ee. Mis on meil selle Optionaluser I sees.
Õpetaja: Mis saab olema siin sees. Ma ei taha veel järgmist slaidi panema.
Õpetaja: Kast ja täpsemalt
Õpetaja: kast. Mille sees on siis ee,
Õpetaja: Ta tagastab tegelikult kasti, aga seal sees on user objekt päris andmetega.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me vaatame seda If Lauset ennem, oli mingi nulliga võrdlus, Kuidas on siin nüüd see,
Õpetaja: milleks nüüd see rehkendab?
Õpetaja: Kas kast on tühi?
Õpetaja: Järelikult siis seda viga ei tule
Õpetaja: ja viga ei tule sisse Logitud kasutaja. Kui tuleb nüüd student, mis meil siis sees on?
Õpetaja: Jah, aga kast on kast, mis on tühi, mille seas on halb?
Õpetaja: Kuidas Nüüd see If lause. Kas Optional user on? Mt on truu? Järelikult käivitub. Viska viga, Pole Kasutame püral.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd vaatame seda neid Variante eriti. Vaatame niukest varianti Ilma optionita.
Õpetaja: Me peaksime tegema user I. Võrdun alla,
Õpetaja: Kui mõinna oleks lugeda midagi taolist koolis
Õpetaja: Mingi asi ei ole on halb.
Õpetaja: Kohe Mingi protsessor hakkab peas Nagu mingi. Mis Nüüd siis
Õpetaja: mis nüüd? Siis Nagu on? On ju versus, kui on meil Niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: see on nagu, et on midagi. Vaata Vastus on. See on nagu rõve ju.
Õpetaja: Iga kord, kui nagu midagi on, pead vaatama, et ei ole, On all, Ei ole, on all, ei ole, on all. Wow, Misasja Kogu aeg oleks selline. Teema ei ole all tegelt On nagu hea olukord. Vaata,
Õpetaja: on midagi, millega. Teha.
Õpetaja: Kui lihtne oleks, vaadata nagu. Et kui leidsin midagi, siis tee midagi.
Õpetaja: See Räägib meiega Nagu enamvähem inimene Ise
Õpetaja: ju see võrdub nalliga ja ei võrdu. Nalliga Enam Ei ole nii mõnus seda asja vaadata.
Õpetaja: See on ee, ideaalne asi selliseks olukorraks, kui neil ongi vaja põhimõtteliselt kandida nagu Do In One,
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja teada, kas on või ei ole ja meil on potentsiaalselt. Kui on midagi, siis on ka vaja sisu.
Õpetaja: Aga ainult siis
Õpetaja: või kui ei ole sisu ja vaja mingit tegevust käivad, vahet pole seal otse. On tegelikult ee. Parem meetod ka. Mida meie nagu tahaks kasutada.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: ehk siis, kui me otsime andmebaasist mingisugust Aa,
Õpetaja: ee, rida. Ma ei räägi praegu siin. Ee listist, onju? Listis on väga lihtne. See on tühi list või? Või? Seal on mingeid objekte, on Ju seal saab vaadata ka meetodid. Mingi ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Aga meil üksikobjektide puhul, kus me otsime andmebaaside andmeid Programmiliselt Me ju siin ei tea, Kas tuleb midagi või ei tule, Sest see sõltub ju sisendist. Sisend ei tule meie programmist. See tuleb väljapoolt
Õpetaja: Järelikult me peame sellele mõtlema. Iga Jumala kord, kui me otsime mingisuguseid andmeid
Õpetaja: Ee, andmebaasist. Me peame nagu programmeerimise mõttes mõtlema seda ka. Mis siis, kui
Õpetaja: kui ei Leia, mis siis saad. Mida siis pole anda?
Õpetaja: Kas ta viskab mingi vea?
Õpetaja: Saadate mingi ja saab ta kuskil üldse Sellepärast mingeid andmeid vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Me peame nagu mõtlema sellele, et kui me pärime mingeid andmeid. Vaata, eriti kui on see üks rida. Me peame mõtlema seda, et Noh, ka. Listiga peame võibolla mõtlema, mis siis saab, onju? Aga. Aga ühe rea puhul siis võtab meile appi see sama,
Õpetaja: kus on või ei ole, on või ei ole.
Õpetaja: Sest et kui on, siis me soovime niikuinii midagi teha. Nende andmetega. Kui ei ole, siis on vaja ka midagi. Vaata, on ju.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: siis. Ee. Minu soovitus. Loomulikult ongi. Edaspidi on see, et kui me teeksime selle meetodi uuesti, pole vaja, Te saate käsitsi samamoodi, kui teil on endiselt user. Siin
Õpetaja: saab seda käsitsi ka veel muuta.
Õpetaja: Mis te teete? Lihtsalt lööge üks tühike ette.
Õpetaja: Suure tähega päev.
Õpetaja: Tuled useri juurde, Paned Ee, nurgalised, suured algavad.
Õpetaja: Nurgalised suled lõppevad. Ja I love optimizing Control alt Ilo.
Õpetaja: Noh, läheb korda ka, aga ma samal ajal näitan,
Õpetaja: et loomulikult disainimise Hetkel on parem, et valitsed selle Koeri Point. Instants
Õpetaja: Tuled, valid, tähendab see valiku kohe alguse Ära siit valid. Optional.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et user Wrappitakse sisse, pannakse ta hästi.
Õpetaja: No ma panen mingi suvalise atribuudi siit praegult korra, Lihtsalt, et, ee. Lihtsalt midagi näidata.
Õpetaja: Tuli siia juurde meetod, mis? Kohe pani meile selle koodirea meie eest ise ära on nii
Õpetaja: See on See asi, mida me absoluutselt alati eelistame.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui korra minna sinna klassi sisse. See on vaatamise koht.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on meetodid.
Õpetaja: Get viis Present viis Emp.
Õpetaja: Aga ma nüüd näitan seda, mis programmeerimises teeb. Elu väga, väga mõnusaks.
Õpetaja: Eelkõige on Orel Strobe.
Õpetaja: Kui te näete nagu kuskil Kirjaviisis T tähte. See tähenda sümboliseerib taipi.
Õpetaja: Aga te ei sümboliseeri konkreetset. Type Kuidas Ors töötab? On niimoodi
Õpetaja: üks variant. On see, et kui objekti pole, siis ta viskab vea. Süsteemi vigu visatakse sõnaga.
Õpetaja: Aga teine asi on see, et kui seal on sisu, siis ta tagastab selle Sama objekti, mis seal
Õpetaja: kasti sees on.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui sina pärid kuskilt andmeid.
Õpetaja: Ja see. Need andmed on optional kasti sees,
Õpetaja: kui sul On see objekt olemas,
Õpetaja: siis selle objekti sees. Sa saad käivitada meetodid
Õpetaja: ja tema siis teeb täpselt seda.
Õpetaja: Ma just rääkisin.
Õpetaja: Kui kasti sees midagi pole siis on seal programmeeritav koht, kus visatakse süsteemi viga Kusagasti See, et midagi on,
Õpetaja: siis ta võtab keti abil selle sisu ja Annan sulle.
Õpetaja: Ee, see ee. Meetod on ülihea meetod. Kuna ta võimaldab kirjutada meil koodis väga lühidalt siukest. Case,
Õpetaja: et kui siin on mingi sisu. Anna mulle see ja lõpetame siin selle jutu ära. No kui ei ole, siis viska mingisugune viga. Mida mina ütlen, et sina viskad
Õpetaja: Ülihea asja. Kõik tuim on põhimõtteliselt. See on väga hea asi.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis viga ei viska, aga tagastab mingi objekti
Õpetaja: ja saad selle objektiga midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Kui seal on midagi. Teisel juhul saad ka siis käivitada tegevust, Kui ei ole, aga otseselt viga ei viska. See on nagu See põhiline Tegelikult, see.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on nagu ülihea.
Õpetaja: On. Ee, väga, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Ee, Teeme siis võibolla siinkohal lõunapausi,
Õpetaja: aga enne kui me Seda teeme.
Õpetaja: Ee, Teeks selle asja niimoodi korda, et läheks sinna sisse. Korraks kustutaks kõik ära.
Õpetaja: Sotsioloogiline user meetodi seest.
Õpetaja: Me oleme nüüd muutnud seda meetodit ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Teeme ainsalt selle asja ära. Et Me kutsume välja selle meetodi.
Õpetaja: Ütlen user Repositor I. Kasutan seda muutuja nime, Mis siin. Real Kolmteist on? Onju?
Õpetaja: Välja nimi, vaid ta on Control F. Üleval Pool peaks olema kuskil meie meetod find user Buy
Õpetaja: mitte, See see on see, et hakka konstrueerima midagi Päris meetod.
Õpetaja: Control B ütleb, mida? Ta ootab sisse.
Õpetaja: Username password ja status. Noh, me ka enda, nagu lihtsalt teeme uuesti Kus me. Saame need väärtused?
Õpetaja: Mängumaa On ju mingi maailma lühikene? Nagu
Õpetaja: Millegi muuga meil eriti toimetada pole
Õpetaja: ju Siis sellega midagi saab teha.
Õpetaja: No ta juba pakub. Vaata, ta näeb, et ee, parameetrina läheb User Names Ring Ina.
Õpetaja: Ta juba põhimõtteliselt pakub, et kas tahad siia kirjutada Loogi? Indrek Westpunkti. No Davai.
Õpetaja: Mis ma siia? Kirjutan Nii öelda. Password I.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Login Request Status Login Request Get.
Õpetaja: Aga siin ei ole. Ee. Staatust. Seal on ainult välja username. Kui te ei mäleta, siis vaatame,
Õpetaja: ei ole Mul, Ee, seda informatsiooni.
Õpetaja: Jah, et
Õpetaja: see on see. Vaata, see on nagu ma näen seda asja, et te hakkate frontend I viima. Mingeid Väärtuseid Frontend. Ist. Te ise kirjutate Niukse Rea et saada sinna staatus. Pane see alati. Aa, No miks sa peaks väljast poolt tulema? No Aga muidu, mul ei ole siin. Ju. Ma ei saa ju seda ära täita. Ju?
Õpetaja: Mis siin olema peab. Aa, Triin ka vä Panen Siis
Õpetaja: no enne kui pausile läheb, mis läheb edasi?
Õpetaja: Mis on saalis Vaikus? Aga mis sa näed, mis me teeme? Edasi
Õpetaja: toon vitsa kohe Või Ja pärast lood ise vitsa.
Õpetaja: No pane. Teaduses Ärge öelge jälle. Jah, Kas. Kas kutsume välja meetodi, mis midagi tagastab? See on meetodi nimes
Õpetaja: või meetodi nimeks Find User.
Õpetaja: Kui sa kutsud välja meetodi, mis midagi tagastab ja soovid selle informatsiooniga midagi edasi, teha, pane see muutuasse,
Õpetaja: Keegi võiks öelda. Jaa, aga mul ei ole selle informatsiooniga midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Sa ei tee ju midagi täitsa.
Õpetaja: Püsib andmeid On ju et kui Sa ütled, et sul ei ole selle objektiga midagi teha. Siis Mis sa seda meetodit välja kutsud? Mis sulle midagi annab, sest see on ka tema kogu tegevus. Ja saada mingit notification It või? Ta ei tee mingit action It või midagi protsessi.
Õpetaja: Balt Enter,
Õpetaja: Seisan siin selle nimevaliku juures. Mingi tüüp on paigas. Otsene võsav.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla muute nimi?
Õpetaja: Siin on ka ülilihtne vastus.
Õpetaja: Miks user?
Õpetaja: Kas ta tagastab Useri Ei, Ta ei tagasi puserit. Kui ma vaatan tüübid. Ta ei taga skuserit,
Õpetaja: mida ta tagastab.
Õpetaja: Pops on väga hästi aga oksjonilkaste kus sees saab käia ainult.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla siis Jah, see on ju kõige parem asi praegu, mida hetkel saaks kasutada, et
Õpetaja: ta peegeldab seda tüüpi Nii, noh, nüüd on ilusti
Õpetaja: olemas. Ja siit kohalt. Siis pärast jätkame. Teen selle Comiti ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, kes kaasas ei jõudnud selle osaga käia, Saate selle arust
Õpetaja: Tsau
Õpetaja: ei tulnud üldse seda muuta. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, oota see menüü. Mis seal filmi menüü on? Nagu Context Action.
Õpetaja: Tema jaoks On nagu tähtis ja aru saada, et, ee, mis on see selle asja ümbrus? Kui sa praegu soovid abi
Õpetaja: mõnda, et ta pakub igasuguseid Asju, mis, ee, sulle nagu eks abipakku jääb.
Õpetaja: Sinul on see, et sul ei ole seda muutunud, onju? Anda nagu märka. Nagu. Et kuidas ta neid üldse. Nagu mõtled.
Õpetaja: Sa oled selle meetodi peal. Ütleb sulle. Tule aita mind pirnikene Okei, Muidu näiteks
Õpetaja: ei ole kiire ka midagi sõdima ma juba nägin.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin saab ise kirjutada paar tähte. Või saad lihtsalt otsida valikust.
Õpetaja: Ee, kollane Pirne on. Tema jaoks on tähtis Ümbrus,
Õpetaja: Kus sa oma selle vilkuva joonekesega oled? Tema jaoks. Ta saab aru, et praegu sa keskendud sellele kohale,
Õpetaja: et ta ei tea, kuhu Sa vaatad oma silmadega, Mida sa mõtled, pole?
Õpetaja: Ta pole abikaasa, kes peaks ee, telepaatiliselt kõike nagu aru saama, mida teine inimene mõtleb?
Õpetaja: Lähme Teeme nüüd selle Lunchi ära.
Õpetaja: Sobib, et oleme tagasi. Siis kaine nagu täi
Õpetaja: Davai Minge sööma. Ärge kulutage oma aega saate pärast siin topsile need lahti, Nii, aga
Õpetaja: Ja stopile lausa oleks mõistlik panna.